two
[Music]
hello hello it is monday my dudes april
18th
welcome welcome
to a huge show-stopping
show
other h3 podcast give it up people give
it up
give it up
we have so much fun uh oliver tree's
about to call in
he didn't win the kids choice award as
you guys may have heard that he lobbied
hard against he humiliated himself
frankly the way he begged for votes and
he still didn't win
so we are bringing what we've done for
him is we have set up our own award
to honor him so he's going to be calling
in
after that
we've got the good mythical morning chef
uh chef josh
how do you say his lesson share
he's a share
chef josh cher
we've been wanting to get this viking
pizza of loves with the kebab and the
sauce and all that
chef josh has
he has uh volunteered
his expertise to prepare that for us
which i'm very excited
and finally
my parents are calling in too because my
dad was at a baseball game over the
weekend and stabbed a ball
the thing you guys didn't hear about
that is someone actually tried to fight
him
oh let's go i'm just saying like this
man he must be stopped i told my mom
it's not too late for the divorce
she needs to be free we all need to be
free this isn't too far it's too much
sorry gary stans
today we have no sponsors because uh
i am an existential threat to
gay rights
and all progress
so of course our wonderful uh
fans have taken upon themselves to read
all of our sponsors
and
to have them uh
can't uh not sponsor or not to uh
support us so
we are um
i'm very you know
i'll just say this it's a i'm very
thankful to our members
now's the time and the reason i say that
is to thank our wonderful members
who support the show by becoming members
because
it makes this show kind of uh
bulletproof
to stuff like this even though it's
painful and
emotionally it just doesn't it's just
painful that you know people would do
that
there it is
and you know the other thing is like you
you like
you expect a little more of the sponsors
in a way but i get it there is you know
it's just transactional for them but you
know i feel like i
i put so much into the good our our good
partners and
it's kind of crazy when they just drop
you like a bag of dirt one over some
[ __ ] but
there you go i want to encourage you
guys if you love the show and you want
to support us and you don't want to get
uh
you know
you want to help us weather stuff like
this then it's a good time to become a
sponsor or a member actually right so
thank you thank you peace and love and
thank you to all the members
love you guys appreciate that so much
uh uh okay so we are
gonna bring on oliver right now yeah
they're jumping on uh right now so give
me just a minute so like i was saying
oliver
you know he was begging
he was posting he was posting all over
his social medias
uh pretty humiliating that to like
debase himself so hard and then to still
lose to dixie dimiglio
i would
humiliating is one word for pathetic
comes to mind pathetic definitely nice
thank you lina
yeah definitely put that i mean both
what are you called pathetic and
humiliating oliver tree
yeah
did the map on that one
um
and you know
that award's kind of a curse too when
you see uh how many you know we
discussed that when he called in uh the
uh
previous winners list has some
questionable characters in there yeah i
believe uh
you know what's crazy is lee harvey
oswald won a kid's choices right yeah i
think maybe for the category that we
have him nominated for for
greatest
tick-tock media star social media cowboy
that goes on and on
wait wait
wait if we're waiting for oliver the
pizza is here and ready no he just
hopped on so i'll let him in right now
one second wait it's like hot and
ready he's literally here right now oh
[ __ ] hey dude sorry
we'll do this and then we'll do this
okay okay i'm gonna rush oliver off he's
not important he's not that important
yeah yeah exactly all right one second
let me just get him queued up here
there he is there he is
uh all right dude what the all right so
here can you hear me oliver
i guess
i think i can hear you what do you want
i see i see what you're doing you're
over compensating for the giant l you
took by having all your gold records
behind you
is that right
are you serious right now just just be
real with me man
are you being serious
well i don't know i'm not i'm not like a
psychologist but that's my
analysis mean i'm not credentialed what
these things
yeah
yeah is that all of them just four
no i have way more but honestly they
take two to three months to come so we
just got my song when i'm down just went
gold yesterday so which one
got a couple platinum plaques
of course
but this is just my manager's spot i
don't live anywhere right now so this is
just what he had
oh that's interesting you don't have a
uh you don't have you don't you can't
afford rent or what's happening
well i don't know things have been
pretty rough and um
after you know i put out my country
album cowboy tears and
you know nobody listened to it and
yeah
take your time yeah
it's just you know it's been rough and
you know the label takes all the money
and
you know i had to move back in with my
parents
it's just
it's been a rough period last
three years hang on we're piping in the
sad music for you go ahead
no
thumb doesn't sit right with me
when you get nominated
for an award and
they don't even invite you to the awards
ceremony that is weird actually isn't it
yeah i'm trying to figure out what's
going on here
i can't be the only one
[Laughter]
wait they didn't invite you
[Music]
well why why would they nominate you and
not even invite you
the whole thing's freaking rigged man
i don't even think that i was ever even
gonna have a chance at this
he was the award
ceremony liaison last year all right
you're you're a mess buddy yeah okay oh
pull yourself together man
let's let's keep some dignity
let's just keep some digging i'm not
crying i just got some dirt in my eye
yeah you're inside
there's no breeze where's your where's
the dirt coming from
that was out in the yard working right
he's got to earn his keep something yeah
you're earning your keep out in the yard
all right oliver listen it don't feel
too bad it's dixie dimelio she's a
juggernaut i i mean it was a long shot
to begin with you give it your best
chance but here's the good news
we have
put together
because we love you so much and we
believe you were robbed
we've put together our own
award ceremony for you
[Music]
we want to honor you
look at this
talk about this we made our own blimp
stop
are you kidding me and this thing is
even more exclusive this is only the
only one that exists
that is freaking incredible dude
yeah oh my god when can i take it well
hold on let's announce let's just let i
want to give you the whole
uh what's the french saying akruterman
the whole trimmings
thank you i want to do the whole thing
for you okay
so let's roll our nominees go ahead we
have a whole we've prepared we want to
honor you as proper as possible so go
ahead ian
hey it's the 2022 h3 choice awards
here are the nominees for best mullet
cowboy musician social media star who
thinks life goes on and on and on and on
and on and on oliver tree
billy ray ciris
[Music]
all right wow that's exciting
so we put it to a vote we have a
our own academy
and so obviously we're very biased
towards you what was the top what was
the full name of the of the award
oh it was um best cowboy
based uh
mullet cowboy social media star whose
life goes on and on and on right or
something to that we kind of we tailored
it perfectly for you so it's like how
can you lose
anyway drum roll please i have the
envelope here with a little green tape
over it so it's really good
the winner is
by unanimous decision
wait is this right is this real
that's the vote
i'm sorry oliver it was billy ray cyrus
[Applause]
he's a legend oliver he's a legend
he fell off dude be a little gracious
and defeat jesus be gracious are you
kidding me after everything i've done
for your stupid [ __ ] show dude i'm
sorry i really didn't expect billy to
win i i thought it would be a shoe-in
for all of her with the on and on thing
and the social media thing [ __ ] joke
you're telling me you're [ __ ] joking
me right now is billy ray even on
twitter or anything
um he might even be banned i don't know
i don't even think billy ray cyrus is on
social media but yeah he beat you that's
that's
literally a [ __ ] dude tell me right now
tell me right now who is picking the
award
no we we have a whole academy we don't
disclose the members obviously you and
dan
we don't disclose the members because we
we don't want to have outside influences
on the judges but i can assure you it's
very similar because i know hila would
have voted for me this is [ __ ] i can
assure you it was fair it was a total
fair free election yeah respect the
democratic party frankly how dare you
accuse us of otherwise but yeah if we
can get ahead how dare you ethan how
[ __ ] dare you hey all of our dudes
lights on when you get canceled time
after time and this is how you [ __ ]
repay me i i voted for you i i'm shocked
frankly that that billy won
by the way that you say that because you
said it was a unanimous
right yeah that's weird i must have put
in the wrong bubble
no i must have put in the wrong bubble
because there was only two it was a
little confusing on the form yeah
you know do you have because you're in
the music biz do you happen to know his
agent or someone that you could put us
in touch with to send him the blog
yeah
maybe you could ask he might be on your
label atlantic or whatever
uh billy ray cyrus jr
no not no that's senior i think yeah
senior oh no i only know his son
[Laughter]
all right well well we're gonna have to
figure out how to get this to billy
obviously right yeah we'll dm them
we'll find we'll figure it out but
the good news is there is
the second place
does get a massive consolation prize so
while you did not win the blimp
we actually sent to your
address um
we went to the yellow pages and looked
up and found uh
your parents house yeah we looked up
your parents house and found them in the
yellow pages we sent if you go to your
front door we have now the consolation
prize at your house
one sec hey can someone go grab the box
yeah i got you
who's that
why does he sound like that that's weird
i think that was his mom maybe oh oh
that was his mom does your mom sound
like a dude
why does your mom sound like that [ __ ]
he's this dude
we go all out wait wait do you know you
guys know paul wait paul
paul what's up paul you got a issue with
your okay thanks paul i don't wanna
all right peace and love dog what was
that he's a fan
why does he sound like that though i'm
not sure
what the hell high-pitched paul
right
all right open it up
what is it dude come on they're knocking
you kind of open it
up
not gonna ruin the surprise
let me get a [ __ ] drum roll at least
we got the drum rolls
going
i can't hear it
okay oh well we can hear it the audience
can hear it yeah
[Music]
ready yeah go ahead
[Music]
what the [ __ ]
are you [ __ ] kidding me
yeah
show it wait show it show it
[ __ ] [ __ ] show it
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
that thing is cursed bro
oh i wouldn't do that i wouldn't do it
oh don't don't
what are you doing you're [ __ ] out
dude
know he did us a huge favor by
destroying that thing because we would
never get rid of that yeah
oh my god dude
i am worried for him man
i feel relieved knowing he destroyed
that thing vintage i feel like we're all
gonna die final destination hey i got
nothing to do i never touched the thing
yeah i didn't buy the thing that was all
ian it was given to dan and now oliver
destroyed it if anyone's dying it's you
three
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude after everything i
[ __ ] did i kept the lights on for the
[ __ ] h3 podcast yeah
he's so [ __ ] uh you that thing has a
legitimate curse on it oliver yeah
probably shouldn't have done that
i don't give a [ __ ] ethan cline
all right
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude well
congratulations that was your prize
bring it up
clean it up mom
wait he got the let me see the fit on
your boy
oh my goodness
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude
everything i [ __ ] did
ethan klein i will [ __ ] come to your
house i will [ __ ] find you you think
what [ __ ] jack did was scary i'll
show you [ __ ] scary [ __ ] i
just cut him off
[Music]
that was too far that was too far he
hung up he i didn't actually cut him off
he hung up
listen i have no control over the vote i
don't know what you guys i don't know
how billy won i mean that was like a
shoot in for him it's now that he's off
the line i i voted for billy you built
it for really yeah yeah yeah
better mullet i mean billy has a whole
discography yeah your music i mean icky
breaky heart
yeah well for once billy's going through
a divorce right and two he makes better
music right now
achy break your heart you can square it
up i'd say oliver's got an achy breaky
heart right about i think so
he's not gonna have a heart after that
well we wish him well guys you know
oliver tree he's touring he's got his
cut little cowboy album cowboy tears or
something
and uh we wish him well we wish him out
he's a good sport yeah we we like oliver
maybe next year i hope next year yeah
you know
well we can do another award show for
him it's gonna be stiff competition
anyway let's not bring the sh let's not
keep the chef waiting
uh chef josh sharer am i saying his name
right doesn't am i saying your name
right share oh yeah you're nailing it
okay great is that your nail in it
that's for the first yeah so of good
myth the good mythical kitchen
has kindly offered
uh graciously offered
to cook us the kebab pizza that love has
been going on and on about
nice to meet you
here come have a seat chef josh is that
is that oh
what do you like better mythical chef
josh is good yeah a little put a little
uh respect on it thank you
so we have here mythical chef josh
now this looks incredible love does this
look right to you because that looks yes
that looks very very good and then tell
me tell me about the meat on that
because it's the place yeah the meat on
that zach sent us like a an incredibly
specific uh i want to call like a fact
sheet on everything that should be on a
kabab pizza uh he said the meat is
typically pork and he said it wasn't
like the euro meat that they shave off
and so we did like a pork chop and we
actually like bought a shawarma machine
from amazon uh we stacked it all up we
marinated it and like the onion juice
all the spices oh my god shaved it off
made the sauce fresh made the dough
extra thin all swedish style
i actually made that that document right
there so yeah that was truly authentic
if you followed that yeah yo this is so
good tell me about the sauce so uh the
sauce i mean no one knows what's in any
kebab sauce right like it very it really
is a secret i mean we went with a little
bit of like uh thinned out yogurt with
water some spices uh chopped up cucumber
a little bit of bell pepper and
mayonnaise damn and lemon juice thank
you man we also made a bonus pizza
because you're talking about swedish
pizza i feel like you can't not talk
about the shrimp banana and curry pizza
wait is there cheese on this yeah but uh
dude said like not too much cheese is
that right the yuen shopping style
so we tried to get it as authentic as
possible oh my god
i must say it looks very very accurate
like extremely good
hold on i'm gonna go
yeah please man dude this is incredible
thanks dude look at that oh yeah that
looks perfect actually yes so you got
pork
which has like the kebab flavor yeah
yeah
the kebab sauce
light cheese light sauce it's actually i
mean it's pretty simple uh swedish style
pizza like you got that super thin
crackery crust on it it's got a little
bit of like dough conditioner in the
dough to kind of make it extra light
i mean it's like damn near like a
domino's thin crust pizza did you try it
i haven't even too i haven't even eaten
this yet yeah try it
come get a slice so much this
come on i'm i don't you don't need pork
i ain't pork but grab me one yeah yeah
what the [ __ ]
everyone's sleeping on the shrimp and
banana peaches though y'all don't want
that oh [ __ ] is that what that is shrimp
banana curry powder dude this is like
swedish pizza extraordinaire is that
right love
the shrimp banana do you [ __ ] with that
uh well
i don't want to be picky but usually i
have never heard of the shrimp on there
it's very possible that there's a
version of it but
that style of pizza is very typical in
sweden with banana so with banana curry
in college i had a bunch of swedish
friends uh mostly from from malmo
and like the [ __ ] they would put
together for their meals they'd be like
oh we're having taco night and then they
just dump like and pineapple and like
water chestnuts and top it with like
yogurt you'd be like this is tacos i'd
be like i have no idea how this
translates but that's rad mm-hmm
yeah yeah it's like
a method away from sweden so
so mythical uh chef matt matthew matt
matthew or matt
who me
wrote neither one of those i don't know
why did i say matt josh
where did matthew i'm sorry i don't know
man evan dude it's been a long day man
then
it's good
um you went to culinary school what what
how did you end up working for the guys
didn't do that at all i um
i just like get drunk in college and
make really stupid foods and i started a
blog about it and then someone gave me
like a book deal
really which is pretty wild yeah yeah so
your your
uh blog must have been pretty sick
pretty uh
no no no no one read it that's the crazy
thing
i it won like an award from a magazine
for some reason
i would write just like the dumbest [ __ ]
um a lot of us kind of comedy writing
right like one thing i wrote was about
the velocity diet because the paleo diet
was really big at the time and i was
like [ __ ] that bro you gotta go to the
next level and only eat what a
velociraptor would eat oh just like yeah
whole sides of animals which it's funny
because now you have the carnivore diet
that people are actually doing that's
real yeah so i guess i'll just ahead of
my time with that you work but but yeah
and then um
i've been working for rhett and link
about four and a half years now oh wow
two years ago we launched our own
channel uh mythical kitchen
and uh yeah we're just we're just doing
it awesome amazing
josh this slaps dude good thank you that
was insane and by the way the way you
cook the meat it's like perfectly
get that little bit of charcoal
yeah yeah yeah
that's a good stuff i don't usually eat
shrimp but i'm gonna do it
you is it a is it a kosher thing no i'll
say
by the way oh yeah a fellow hux man
i get a shot of that one too okay no
this is very
people yell at me for pineapple on the
pizza banana on the pizza is [ __ ]
insane yeah it's not good
it's pretty i
i'm normally one of those people that's
like any flavor that you enjoy anything
can go together no there's like not a
worse combination of foods to me than
banana and curry what would you do like
what's worse than this
[ __ ] there's a human [ __ ] right that's
yeah
next level after shrimp banana and curry
human feces i mean i'll still eat it but
like you know i'm not happy right it's
pizza like i'll eat any pizza and this
is proof of it i can't do it i just took
it off i'm sorry
so
how did you end up uh working for them
you went from you wrote this book was
the book successful what was it called
not at all no no it was called it was
called the culinary bro down cookbook
that was the uh the the name of the blog
um but we just go for sale people still
buying it yeah people you can buy it on
amazon or like some other better
retailer you get paid when they buy it
no i think it's gotta earn the royalties
but if enough people buy it eventually
i'll get like six cents what's the best
thing for people to do to support you
right now oh uh best thing to do um one
we're nominated for two webbies right
now that's pretty solid uh in mythical
kitchen is nominated for the uh food and
drink video that's pretty bad and then
uh my podcast with my co-host nicole
nyeti it's called a hot dog as a
sandwich that's nominated for the arts
and cultures uh yeah go watch the videos
subscribe to tick tock
we pissed off a lot of people speaking
of pizza with a uh we made a spokane
style pizza which is not a real thing
we're just doing a goof we're just new
goofing out there and we put
strawberries and salmon on it
goofing baby
and um a lot of people from spokane
thought it was real uh and really pissed
them off so if you go like uh i don't
know talk [ __ ] somebody from spokane
that'd be big that's good [ __ ] them yeah
right i know it's basically idaho like
get out of here you pissed off gordon
ramsay too right
off gordon ramsay ali if you're watching
we have videos ellie if you're watching
i'm sorry
she's from the spokane area
my girlfriend i'm sorry but she is oh
she starts up well
you guys are going to break up obviously
well we we made a gordon ramsay's beef
wellington out of only 7-eleven
ingredients oh i love that
hot dogs
pull it up it's on there and then gordon
ramsay did he respond
i want that
i want that
and i made like a 20-minute video
shooting on him for uh making the
world's worst grilled cheese in a
youtube video the cheese wasn't even
melted the bread was burnt you know
he's richer than god he doesn't need
anything you know i feel like he often
i disagree with his recipes a lot and i
got to say i start with
the eggs i don't know if you agree his
runny nasty [ __ ] eggs where he's like
you got to put like a shitload of like
cream fresh yeah and then it just turns
into this gooey swab yeah it's like a
chunky pudding
if i'm eating eggs i want to be eating
eggs damn like i want like that denny's
so you agree i agree yeah i don't i
don't agree with his egg take either
it's disgusting it's just unforgivable i
i fully agree with that i uh and then he
also executive produced what i think is
one of the worst movies of all time it's
called burnt starring bradley cooper
where it's basically an autobiography of
gordon ramsay and it's just bradley
cooper uh being like i was a drug addict
but now i'm a bad boy chef but they
never explained what he was addicted to
and he just kind of screams at people
for like two and a half hours over uh so
pretty solid
do you think there's actually an issue
with like
have you ever excuse me have you ever
worked in a kitchen yeah not not too
long those but just before i got in the
media i was you know working for a
catering company and then worked for a
restaurant for a couple months
what are your thoughts on like kitchen
culture because there's this whole
culture of like
the man in charge and he's like i'm
gonna run my kitchen like it's [ __ ]
the military and you look at gordon
ramsay and all these famous chefs and
they kind of get a pass for being like
abusive to employees because it's like
this is how we run this [ __ ] is do you
think that's a problem oh it's a huge
problem and i think it like what gordon
ramsay's doing even if it's for
entertainment people are always like oh
he's just acting it's like well that's
worse than even because you're implying
that he knows he shouldn't be doing that
and when you're putting that out in
media right then people go like oh
that's the way i should act this man is
very successful he screams at people
he's abusive ergo the path to success is
that when it's like actively harming
society yeah he should stop that right
it's interesting that like that one
profession specifically gets a pass yeah
where the rest has moved on like you
can't work in a desk job and i'm just
like dan you [ __ ] idiot the feed
isn't up or whatever it is it's raw you
[ __ ] bellend or whatever he says you
know
like he's insane you know and we think
it's it's it's fine but it's not is it
no yeah i mean it's it's similar with uh
like sports or like you know any other
profession that you think is uh i don't
know something like creative right like
you hear stories of like uh musicians
just like [ __ ] trashing hotel rooms
and throwing [ __ ] at their assistant
people like ah sick do you rock and roll
baby yeah and that same thing is in you
know restaurant kitchens except 99 of
people in restaurants are making
somewhere near the damn minimum wage
yeah i'm just trying to figure it out
and so no if you're like screaming at
people making minimum wage trying their
best you're just a huge you're an
[ __ ] yeah yeah i agree so there seems
to be a real uh beef with uh gordon on
your side yeah he's like winning in the
life end of things you know he
definitely has taken a w in every aspect
i i did uh i showed up to the kitchen
nightmares no not uh hell's kitchen set
recently with a sign that said wrestle
me gordon
um and then he did not take the
challenge but there's a standing
invitation to challenge i wonder if he
knows who you are and he's just like all
this [ __ ] guy man
yeah any parking lot in the greater
burbank area they'll wrestle gordon
ramsay and that's that's the promise
you're a big guy i don't know if people
can tell how tall are you uh about six
too and you you obviously work out so i
think you'd [ __ ] you'd destroy him
that's what i'm saying man yeah you
destroy him he's scared yeah i think he
i mean i don't want to like you know i
noticed i noticed you didn't even finish
it are you on a diet what's happening no
or is it on the diet it's talking you
don't want talking pretty much i can i
can really stuff it no it's just curious
because i feel guilty
well it's your pizza i don't know it's
your own food
yeah you're the chef i mean if it hurts
your own feelings
you're pretty good you guys try the
banana one oh there's only two only
only we've tried the banana one [ __ ]
i've got the bananas you got no excuse
on the banana [ __ ] ab get over here you
got to spar later i can't oh my god you
got a pack on the way i'm going to do a
court revenue you [ __ ] bellend eat
the pizza
nobody cameron sam
who says it's bulking season boys come
on yeah we're getting in there
banana pizza dude yeah i'd like to try
it i wish you were here i think you
would love this pizza
uh so
this saw if okay so let's be a little
bit more like analytical the sauce
didn't sound quite right
uh
the the sauce has a little bit of garlic
and i've heard rumors that there's fanta
in the sauce fantastic wild rice yeah
is it orange
i've had three people called uh dm me
since we started talking about it and
say that it's fanta in there dude
another thing i've heard that's a huge
twist on boycott i've heard there's the
nazi soda
oh [ __ ]
to this day
well i mean you know but the origins you
know we're still
oh yeah i like that i've also heard
there's like a jalapeno juice when you
have like maybe get the baby you [ __ ]
believe we didn't we put pickle juice in
it but no jalapenos oh you did
no
basically the juice from jalapenos they
put in there the juice from pineapple
it's a bunch of different rumors that's
going around uh
but yeah i gotta say trips are fake
though what if it's like a red herring
like they're trying to get people to
make [ __ ] here it's very possible i'm
not denying that at all it's very very
possible i gotta say that the mythology
around this sauce is pretty incredible
that nobody
has yet unlocked the secrets like
there's not one guy kebab sauce maker
who went to google and it's like here's
the deal here's how you make it
that's the thing with any food though
right uh the you know secret herbs and
spices and kfc you can combine like 11
of any herbs and spices and it'll pretty
much taste close chemistry as long as
you're
pretty close to kfc as long as you have
like salt fat and msg and things it's
going to taste really good
you know
so you're saying the
oh for real damn take it home all of it
it's yours i'm afraid yeah i'm a fan of
it too this kind of flops dude i i
absolutely love this kebab all your
brains are broken who like that banana
and shrimp pizza it's check it you may
have had a concussion recently don't go
to sleep
it like yeah it may not wake up it
shouldn't work but it kind of does
i don't know right
well i agree let's watch this beef with
gordon ramsay because i'm fascinated by
this
um should i watch this one or should i i
can watch one that's a good one should i
watch it
out of a slurpee
i'm gonna watch yours first oh what
happened
i don't know man
hey gordon do us a favor put in some
earbuds man you got the resources what
the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
what an [ __ ]
come on
this is literally unwatchable on his
part i know that's good
he doesn't even know what's going on
this is a social media manager who's
just like putting an ipad in front of
his face he's watching a blank screen
for all i know yeah like
put in the headphones gordon also that's
a good dish that's it and there was
classic french technique and i blended
the hot dogs with the egg white to make
a hot dog mousse same thing to do with
scallops right you know poached it off
i light up the pizza like a roulade i
think that's a good dish and i thought
uncle gordon would be proud of me
you know not bob
do you ever think of going on like these
uh chef shows no no no not at all i just
like smash my head into a brick wall
instead though
that bad i mean what's the point man you
know you're getting paid like a
a day rate for eight weeks to go through
hell and no one remembers you norman man
i watched top chefs some of those guys
actually stopped me well top chef's the
only one top chef is the show that like
if you're a contestant on there and you
get say top six top eight or whatever um
i mean you're getting restaurant deal
investment your life is kind of i do
love that show but i see what you're
saying the other ones are it's just
there's so many of them it's it's a dime
a dozen right now um but top chef like
they have my absolute respect i've
watched that show every single season
i've re-watched several seasons uh
they're incredible oh that's nice to
hear like do you how many uh can you
name any like hell's kitchen no no no no
me neither
they make them compete for like six
months and then give them like fifty
thousand dollars
it's gonna be like it's kind of insane
like how small the prize is
meanwhile gordon makes like 20 million
per season yeah i mean he's got his own
production company now and they're just
going to start turning all the way out
they got that new show next level chef
they've created a um in a great metaphor
for capitalism three tiers of kitchens
like a crappy one a mid one and a good
kitchen and they'll like physically
shoot contestants down an elevator if
they perform poorly to the bottom
kitchen that's awesome they built and
then in the basement they're executed
yeah exactly exactly and then that's
what's in the food for the next dish
actually i have an interesting anecdote
about um
hell's kitchen
i went with a friend to a season where
you know we sat at a table and tasted
the food and we were doing all that that
was like
four years ago
and it still hasn't aired and the reason
is is because they shoot like 10 seasons
at a time holy [ __ ]
so like they'll shoot literally 10
seasons in the course of like you know
three months
damn yeah incredible what was the food
yet like or did you no
it was the finale mm-hmm
the food was okay it was overhyped yeah
i mean like any any food too that you're
typically gonna be eating on a show like
that it's just gonna be like cold and
made for camera and or were you like
part of the diners that they were like
serving yeah
yeah oh [ __ ] yeah yeah was it
disappointing or did you just like know
that it wasn't gonna be that great it
was a fun experience yeah i mean like
you said it looked nice it was okay
if anyone would like to invite me to an
episode of top chef that that'd be
pretty cool like i'd like to thank you
shout out you know the
food truck challenge you know not even a
guest oh look like an extra walking
around oh yeah they'll get uh one one
snippet of me going like good meatball
you know and i can do that i'll do it
again good meatball
you know it's the audition oh they don't
need you now they got you on camera
they'll just pipe that in and you're you
just played yourself
[Laughter]
all right let me by the way how was this
beef wellington
oh i mean terrible terrible this is um
you know we we don't make food we make
content it's something that i always
kind of say because it's it's true right
like nobody else in the world is ever
gonna eat this except for me thought it
was a funny concept hilarious video but
like can you make a good beef demi-glass
out of beef jerky into slurpee not
really you know you should probably use
like roasted veal bones or whatever um
but i mean i thought it looked cool and
i had a great time making it
yeah i love the concept let me see
it sounds crazy
yeah ultimately i think i crave his
approval like a father i see that yeah
you really yeah you're conflicting
emotions you really just feel rejected
by him
bro this guy just made a huge [ __ ]
video
by reacting to you and screaming no
without earbuds yeah
yeah did his get more views than yours
uh yes yes it did which was a great
metaphor uh real quick i had we have a
really interesting super chat actually
somebody uh donated 20 and said they are
actually a producer that worked on
hell's kitchen and that in real life
gordon is extremely nice he knew
everybody on the cruise name
it's all for show like it's like
that's like the bad thing that i'm
saying right because how many people is
he interacting with in person like let's
say let's say 50 on that day right how
many people are watching that thing
right hold on right what's being put out
into the world isn't that perception
hold on successful
show runner gordon ramsay is a nice guy
right he does have a reputation in the
kitchen
that is really how he treats the staff
when he was there oh really and his boss
was the same way right he had a famous
marco pierre white they nicknamed him uh
like the devil in the white coat yeah
like he has the same reputation that's
how they do it that's just not an act
yeah like he might be nice but that's
real and in the movie burn like bradley
cooper who plays you know the gordon
ramsay uh prototype uh he's just like
you know throwing he's physically
assaulting his staff he's like throwing
dishes against the wall emotionally
physically abusive yeah and then there's
a clip of gordon ramsay promoting the
movie and he's like this is what you
need to be great this is exactly how it
is in my kitchens you know and so it's
like he's standing by it he's not
apologetic and like even when we see
like actual [ __ ] criminal monsters
like mario batali get indicted for just
sexual assault like there's a book from
2003 where a guy was like shadowing
mario batali and writing about him and
he goes like a server came up to them at
brunch and he was eating batali uh and
asked what they wanted for dessert but
he goes like i'll have you for dessert
and like grabs her ass and this guy is
just writing about it as if it was like
a super cool dope thing to do in the
2000s that's crazy [ __ ] bonkers to me
like god clean it up be a [ __ ] person
sorry get worked up no it's it's really
interesting because yeah that guy's
disgraced as hell yeah
what's with the most ogrish dudes being
like the gnarliest in that way because
mario batali is definitely like harvey
weinstein ogre's status
you know what i mean yeah
yeah it's real interesting that whole
culture eh
yeah and it's not it wouldn't even be a
it's the fact that restaurant workers
are like one of the most um
kitchen staff specifically is one of the
most abused
underpaid
workers i'd say in the country yeah and
there's no like recourse right
especially you're working in a
restaurant you're not like i'm going to
go to hr and tell people about this um
and you know if you're working for
someone like a battalion like a gordon
ramsay and then you want to you know
leave they can
[ __ ] you for a black list
from everywhere and so it's just a huge
[ __ ] show which is why i'm glad i live
in media and have a fair amount of
work-life balance so i can make it
through this yeah that's great and
you're you're speaking truth to power
[ __ ] go to rambu [ __ ] yeah but hey
gordon if you want to give me a show
though that'd be pretty cool like
yeah right i mean i don't know he's got
a production company now
so what is this one yeah so this i made
a ramen grilled cheese this is the
original beef where uh i mean you know
we were just messing around in the
kitchen man we started this tick tock
with no plans and so i just put some
ramen inside a piece uh two pieces of
bread with some cheese and then gordon
ramsay [ __ ] on it and so i made a 20
minute response video about how bad his
grilled cheese was that's on youtube if
you want to check that out that's fun so
how many times has he reacted to you
probably like three or four wow yeah
mm-hmm
[ __ ] y'all dude no stop it
no such thing
who am i no stop it no what are you
doing
for for 40 seconds
at least you've got earbuds in munchie's
nightmare is that a doll in the sink
yeah
are you kidding
no
what no are you okay no stop it oh my
god oh come on it's good cooking
oh for freaks let's juice
i toasted both sides of the bread for my
grilled cheese and i believe that you
should toast both sides of the bread for
the grilled cheese because see right
there you're adding cheese to hot bread
so you're already gonna start the
melting process right and then when
you're someone like a donut like gordon
ramsay and you make a video about
grilled cheese and you don't do that his
cheese wasn't melted he could have by
using i gotta see this unmelted cheese
you're talking about that's that is a
brutal condemnation oh yeah to make a
grilled cheese where the cheese is
melted all the way i mean you can't call
yourself a chef agreed especially to
film it and put it online that that's
the crazy thing to me like redo it like
if you're in a restaurant right which
i'm sure gordon ramsay has like more
michelin stars than anybody and if
you're in a restaurant and a dish
doesn't look right you don't send it out
you know you redo it i'd like to take
the craft of making videos pretty
seriously it's the career i've known the
most in my life something doesn't look
right we're not putting it out there
retaking it exactly yeah it's a grilled
cheese also it's not like a [ __ ] you
know 10 hour yeah it's it's 12 minutes
that he could have just been like hey
guys let's do this what a little loser i
agree i mean again richer than god why
does payton have me executed anytime he
wants what's his net worth somebody do a
google search
uh of gordon oh yeah tax gordon ramsay
hashtag ramsey net worth
oh no more plastic cheese
63 million another one says that's a
conservative estimate
somewhere between yeah 63 and 220
million it's definitely more than 63.
i'm thinking 20. that dude has more
fingers and pockets than damn uh
than uh um what's a good analogy there
who's got more fingers and pockets than
uh
that's not bad i was thinking someone in
prison that we don't like because you
know they make their fingers and are the
pockets in jail
someone i mean r kelly he's probably not
more alpha in prison made off's dead
bernie made up
okay epstein maybe yeah oh
okay let's let's continue
stop it
you stop it ramen cheese on toast forget
it
i'd like to ram that somewhere oh in the
toilet yeah i think he was implying that
he wanted to he definitely wasn't
inserting
i didn't like penetrate you that was
that was strange i mean it made me
excited in a way but not in a way that i
like
you know he wants to penetrate you bro
well this is his meme too but i'm
calling [ __ ] i'm sure he would love
to try that and eat that there's nothing
wrong with that they look good to me
yeah what could be the cheese is melted
ketchup on it all right now now i got to
see this gordon ramsay video with the
unmelted cheese
yes because this needs to be seen you
know yeah if you go to the mythical
kitchen youtube we have a we we did like
a response video and we i mean we
diagram it out and break it down
yeah it's truly abhorrent
so
um
let's do this
that's the original video that one right
there this is the original
that's the original let me see i mean
you can see in the thumbnail
the cheese isn't melting let's see let's
take a look
oh please
what do you are the propaganda already
begins
you better
end no ramsay
no did you guys mute it or something
okay
all right get to the [ __ ] point
gordon now
the acidity
in this kimchi around 440. incredible
[Music]
is he always full of [ __ ] when they got
the acidity the [ __ ] better did it no
so that's where he's not full of [ __ ]
and that's like a really easy thing to
do
if you just know the general words
around things like you take a bite of
pizza you're like oh my god the spice of
that meat the fat is well rendered you
get that beautiful texture from the
crispy crust it's nice light airy and
thin the little bit of acid and the
creaminess coming like you know the food
words to say and that's what he does he
says beautiful every three minutes and
it doesn't matter who it looks or tastes
like if you know the vocab you can just
word vomiting interesting interesting
coat all right let's get to the cooking
so he puts it in a whole damn fireplace
trying a little hardcore never heard of
a [ __ ] stove top
right yeah no that's that's obviously
way too hot to cook a grilled cheese and
he knows it you can see him like
trying to remove it from the heat
yeah
gordon no just burnt the hell and also
the cheese started it's too thick it's
the bread's too thick the cheese is too
thick nothing makes sense it's a huge
thick slice of cheese it's not gonna
melt man
they were hard cheeses too wait can i
ask what the [ __ ] is he doing here
yeah he's trying to push it down to see
if he can just like manually mash more
heat into it
like he knows he's messed up the dish
doesn't want to take the extra 10
minutes to redo it
do this each side
and then once you've colored both sides
back out this [ __ ] has three and a half
million views yeah i think a lot of
people are ripping on them though oh
that's good yeah
push it down it's not gonna help dude
it's just
he could have just like even microwaved
it honestly for 30 seconds just so it
looks melted agreed
you know i mean i i've been there before
on set you know something yes
sometimes i have problem melting cheese
when i'm making a grilled cheese and
what i'll do
is i'll blast it in the microwave
to get the cheese started and then end
it on rip it up on the stove that's
perfect that's the way to reheat pizza
i'll microwave it to get the cheese a
little melty and then hit it on the
stove
interesting yeah
here's a better culinary technique than
this i have the uh the dislike uh add-on
that reveals it and yeah oh
gordon my boy let me finish this and i
want to read some comments
dude anytime when next time gordon
ramsay does something we're going to get
you on you gotta be our official anti uh
gordon spokesperson oh god i'd love that
please and eventually he will wrestle me
it's just gonna happen in a tube in a
tub of mornay sauce or something you
know any french mother sauce that gordon
ramsay wants to wrestle me and i'll do
it you think you could outsource him
no but i could out wrestle him in a
classic espanol sauce okay
and that's enough that's enough for me
thanks
with that incredible cheese especially
that pepper berry
it's just gonna be a wonderful
combination and also
it just helps elevate the flavor of that
beautiful
grilled cheese take that out where are
you bro that you don't have access to a
[ __ ] stove in the tasmanian country
home i believe
he's cracking away
beautiful
good cheese all right let's see this is
it
and this
look how crispy that is
beautiful
that's mario batelli as he [ __ ] has a
woman cornered oh god
oh god
yo that cheese is not melted at all
like not even a little bit so many
people had to touch this video before it
went out and not a single person was
like hey let's have like a little bit of
shame not one not one what a [ __ ]
loser this guy is you believe this i'm
incredibly successful
what is this a child's party
he blew on it as if it were molten as if
it were lava
he blew on it that's incredible
you're lying you're lying bro
wait let me read the comment
people making fun of gordon for this
simply don't understand how amazing of a
chef he really is it must take so much
gun exercise to burn a sandwich without
even melting the cheese made truly
impressive that's [ __ ] awesome
thank you for showing me this video this
is part of his lore i mean this is part
of who he is i feel like it is yeah no
this is this has followed him gordon
managed to burn the bread and somehow
not melt the cheese truly a talented
chef
incredible
fantastic you've watched bloodsport john
claude van damme oh i've saw it a long
time ago it's the top break and only
shatters the bottom brick yeah it's kind
of like what gordon ramsay did
well what can i say it's been a great uh
fun time i'm so thankful that you came
and and i actually got to try
this kebab pizza that i personally
thought was incredible wow thank you of
course i'm really excited i think you
can out sauce
if you want to set up the cook off man
we'll do it in the parking lot out here
set up a couple burners mono amano we'll
do like a triathlon wrestle
cook
yeah and then we'll figure out a third
leg so if you want to wrestle me in a
tub of homework days we can do that i
don't know i'm just saying it might be
fun
that's cool
you definitely seem like you could take
me in a on a physical altercation i i'm
deceptively soft i got weak limbs yeah
wow yeah we throw up barely wait a
little bit ethan i barely have operating
muscles at this point so pretty sure
i'm basically gumby at this point
josh what was uh what was your podcast
one more time oh yeah
oh yeah plugs uh mythical kitchen on
youtube and that's same on instagram tik
tok all that mythical kitchen
yup yup and then podcast is called a hot
dog is a sandwich hot dog
podcast are you sure about that
i'm not i'm not we're actually we're
going to be having i think it's separate
and i'll it is if you want to get in
because it's attached the bread is
attached what happens if like the strong
gust of wind detaches it
well you know so a crow comes away and
just kind of picks out the hinge from
the bread is it no longer i mean listen
we don't need to be socrates about it it
was a hot dog so i i once actually
talked to a cartesian metaphysicist for
four hours about whether or not a hot
dog is a sandwich i'm dead ass seriously
you can it was before i started making
videos so it was just like a blog
uh his name was dr calvin normore at
ucla
and uh yeah it was it was uh pretty wild
did you guys make a conclusion no dude
philosophers never make conclusions
right
we eventually got to a hot dog as a
sandwich in so far as a bench is a chair
so if you believe a bench is a chair you
are likely to believe a hot dog bench is
not a chair no it's who thinks a bank's
a chair
well what defines a chair does it fit
the platonic i think it benches the form
of a chair can you sit on it a bench is
a chair is like
a chair traditionally
one person one seat
obviously there are love chairs good for
two people see already the definition it
starts to it's a slippery thing some
benches
architecture to make them know such
thing as a coincidence
the bench the architecture is clear on
what makes a bench it's a minimal
structured
you know what i'm saying it's basically
wood or iron very simple there's two or
three two
that can fit multiple people
generally benches don't have back risks
i'm not saying chairs are benches we're
saying you know bench might be a chair
you know no one's arguing that like a
single chair could be why would you say
that
because it's it's a chair or something
you're designed to study man come on man
come on i'm not having this fight we
have to stay all right
who wants the there's two slices i'm
pulling the audience by the way 66
percent of our fans say that a bench is
a chair see
yeah i'm just saying right side just
saying that's all i'm saying
what the hell y'all talking about
we have two slices of this banana shrimp
who wants uh who wants
uh sam don't really make sam really dug
it and uh zach seemed to really dig no
but don't let this man take any food out
of here i don't want me yeah i've
already drank three of them
right now oh you did those are so good
oh good they hit the formula just right
dude oh my god coke zero good science
good science josh how's it working for
those uh
those rhett and link characters because
those guys aren't real with the iron
fist man they're cruel cruel dudes oh
yeah i mean after the daily lashings
it's like not it's not bad we got like
an aloe station you know we all just rub
each other oh well that's nice uh no
it's one of them
amy they do
amy's trying to grab my slice yo what
the [ __ ] you don't do that around here
baby what
out of your mind these people
crazy
anyway yeah they're great guys and and
uh
that's great i'm glad you're all working
together so nice to meet you likewise
likewise mythical kitchen everywhere
please with peace and love follow our
good friend and [ __ ] gordon ramsay thank
you for the pizza so good
thank you man
thanks for coming very much
thank you
found it thank you what happened
i was dead lifting dead lifting
something just pulled man i got mris
tomorrow i'll keep you updated you see
this is the problem this guy exercising
he's dead lifting and he's cr he's
walking around like a convalescent my
fat ass hey got no body pain
no back pain you see
thanks man you're the greatest
that was fun
wow amazing i'm so sad love that you
couldn't try this
yeah it yes i i am also very sad about
that but
it looks very good it looks very very
very accurate i feel like this sauce
tastes like
right i feel like it tastes right
because i've i've tried to say this
maybe i was unclear in the past but the
sauce on there is not necessarily the
best sauce there is better sauces for
like different things but that sauce is
so perfect in that context that it just
ties everything together so well it
tastes like a mayonnaise a yogurt thing
just hearing what what were in it i
doubt it's the same but i'm not trying
to bash him
draw it and send it to him find out
well the other way around would be even
better
are my parents on the phone
they're not but i just messaged them and
said we were uh going to be ready for
them in a moment so i'll queue it up
so my parents uh here let me let me um
let me familiarize you guys with what's
going on
um
my parents went to a dodger game
okay
dubrick
dubrick
and then my mom posted this
on tick tock and i was just randomly
scrolling ticktock
and this came up on my feed i didn't
know nothing about nobody
and look at this [ __ ]
gary what did you just do
[Music]
he just popped the ball everyone was
yelling and he's a party pooper
sure the minute i get up to go to the
bathroom
gary what did you just do
people apparently didn't believe me
because in the comments it's all like oh
so the the myth is true yeah the myth is
true
my dad lied about it on the show and
said he didn't really do it right
and look at this
not only did he do it he was look at
that face i mean what does it tell i
don't know what that tells you is
that's the face of a man who
steals joy from other people
on the other hand like button you got to
give him some credit because that takes
some balls i think to piss off yeah sure
o.j simpson it takes to murder people do
i get to give him credit
the chat seems to be they're calling him
an icon right now
there's a lot of gary gary stands in the
chat yeah sure
go to the ball game with a man when your
dad is literally making everyone in the
stadium hate you
and see how iconic it is
so
i made a response
i'm glad they in a way they posted this
because a lot of people didn't believe
me that this used to happen
this is my trauma
gary what did you just do
he just popped the ball everyone was
yelling that he's a party pooper can you
see how my mom enables them oh gary
gary
you know
someone came and threatened him
well let's get into that when they hop
on i'm still waiting for him to hop on
imagine his his children his family
sitting with them you've got to see
someone come threaten your dad
no that's that's definitely scary
because his ass can't tolerate a [ __ ]
beach ball
the minute i get up to go to the
bathroom
gary what did you just do
he's like a serial killer too he takes a
picture of it
he needs like a token to remember he's
like dexter morgan mm-hmm
he just popped the ball everyone was
yelling the trophy
unbelievable
so painful
now i haven't actually heard my dad just
said
someone came and threatened him
and
i actually haven't heard more details he
said he'll tell me on the show he's a
showman
right he's saving it for the show yeah i
i think they're coming on right now he
replied to me uh and so
this my dad tweeted out first one and
counting the crowd loved it everyone was
booing him by the way
i love how he popped it too
yeah he took out a pen
and stabbed it
just i mean what kind of [ __ ] person
does that the ball is bouncing and then
some old [ __ ] lunatic grabs the ball
and stabs it with a pen it's like
cartoonishly evil
die
i'm sorry but
people are saying he's based
yeah it's funny to you guys but he's not
your dad
i used to have friends to come over and
be like your dad's so funny i'd be like
you have no [ __ ] idea what i
what my life is
oh i have uh
gary in the waiting room so let me load
them in right now
all right let's get to the bottom of
this nightmare
all right just a moment
connecting
we are connecting my parents you know
oh a finished dish
a lot of love for your stash by the way
in the chat we've been seeing
a lot of love for the stash people
appreciate the look i manicured it this
morning
yeah
oh okay
we don't have audio yet but there's that
iconic shot see donna
hello there she is hello all right mama
dab
welcome
so
you guys went to a dodger game yesterday
that's true
the second one of the season i went with
jessica on thursday
um mom you went to the bathroom what
inning are we dealing with here
it was the
fifth inning i believe
somewhere around mom goes to the
bathroom
now let me ask you this
was this the first beach ball you saw
during the game or was this the
culmination of
many beach balls
i saw a beach ball but it was really far
away and i even posted it
on uh
twitter or tick tock i don't remember
because i was making a joke like oh
there's beach balls
well as what happened thursday the same
thing you know i posted a picture saying
that i was at the dodger game tweeted it
out and people were tweeting back look
out beach balls and you know and stuff
like that uh so yeah it was it was maybe
the it was the
first or second one in our area
that
someone inflated and just started
smashing off people's heads and off of
their eating trays i really doubt that
was happening you're trying to justify
it
i i have no problem so then why is
everyone booing you
uh well
i did get uh someone replied to me and
they said as a kid i would boo you as a
parent in society i applaud you so
[ __ ]
who said that
energetic can i that was one comment out
of 120
uh news that i've i've gotten so far
do you honestly you think that's the
ratio donna one to a hundred and twenty
thousand yes i mean people thought it
was funny no
no that's not well
then joe hold on let me ask mom
were people booing when you came back
yes no they weren't still booing they
were well you know what happened when
people like what was going on when
people started doing this is what i did
wait where's my hand it's there
somewhere how does this
how did this internet thing work
i'm like
bring it bring it you didn't do that i
did yeah i was like mentally ill my
father is mentally ill
i felt like pretty blassy out there or
uh you needed a diagnosis done you would
have died
okay so
my dad is out there by himself my mom's
not even there and he people are booing
him and he's doing this like do you
think you're a super villain or
something
exactly ethan let me show you like this
let me share something with you come on
bring it okay
i was uh keeping score
so i have penn and i had the dodger
uh
roster and the visitors roster because
it comes in the program because i didn't
think i could smuggle in my machete
there is a there there is this giant
scoreboard at the uh
ball game by the way yeah anyway so i
had my pen and when i went to the
bathroom because the fourth inning if
you were watching the game was insane
it was they weren't watching okay well
it was an incredible game and i i was
running out of room
uh because we had so many runs anyways
so i had to go to the bathroom it was
the fifth inning and i said to dad hold
on to my pen if you could you know keep
score for me because he was eating
the line in the restroom was so long so
god knows how long i had been gone but
when i came back
i'm walking down the stairs and i see
your dad and he's like you know stone
face and everyone's booing oh my god
everyone's moving in our section was boo
everyone in our section was booing and
saying what a party pooper he was and
then on top of it
the ball was between his legs no it
wasn't it was on the floor on the ground
between my feet
he had taken my pen and punctured
well i had to plan it out i had no
weapons to use so i knew the pen was
there and i thought if the opportunity
arises i got the pen i'm ready to go so
the ball ended up on the aisle and just
bouncing down the steps and it ended up
right next to me didn't have to get up i
just reached over and grabbed it with my
hand so clearly destiny was telling me
this beach ball wants to die yeah so i
picked it up and no one knew what was
going on it was down on the ground
between my feet picked up the pen and ah
and and i posted a photo proudly posted
a photo of that of course
do you ever wonder if you're the baddie
i don't know
i'm completely
uh
self-righteous
in my position
[Music]
uh
one of the ushers came for the for the
beach ball
oh my god
he was right behind me and i kept him
trying to take the
the deflated ball from your father and
he wouldn't relinquish it but i kept on
saying
gary finally i managed to rip it from
away from his grip and give it to the us
you want to give it to the usher
that's not what happened
there's no ushers going after beach
balls anymore they stopped doing that
like five years ago
the ball okay okay what happened
and then someone came up to confront me
oh yeah wait let's deal with the usher
issue first what happened
ushers do not
wait wait how could you guys have such
conflicting stories
dad says no usher mom says the us
it was a woman well who took the ball
then dad
what made you think she was an usher in
fact she wasn't wearing a uniform hold
the phone who took the ball
badges
who took the ball dad
and she wanted the ball why
who took the ball dad
hershey's the usher she was not and then
who was it what the heck was going on
hold on hold on hold on hold on
everybody chill chill chill dad who took
the ball
uh some rando that woman that came down
that i assume may have been the person
that launched it or something she came
and wanted it and there was still air in
it
and i didn't want it going again so then
i had the joy of actually stomping on it
a few times to get all the air out of
the small hole because the knife makes a
nice deep wound but the pin you know
it's only like
that size so i had to squash it to get
all the air out
come on stop covering up your eyes so
anyway
so then once it was that is psychotic
almost flat then i gave it back to
whoever that was so this woman whose
ball it was
total random it's worse the way you tell
it that
i don't care it was the usher you said
she had a bag
he was the usher
hey dad
between you and the girl you couldn't
okay if they don't know wrapped up if
they don't go after active beach balls
why is she going after a deflated beach
ball can you answer me that the ball
wasn't played when she obviously walked
over here what ball was in play the
beach ball you just said it was flat
i got ball dead um
why do you think they stopped going
after beach balls
i'm sorry why do you think they stopped
going after beach balls
um
because the crowd likes it
and it's harmless
it's not harmless
nobody's getting hit in the head or
their food launched that's a fallacy
okay here ethan i have an idea
i'd like to propose
the next dodger game come along with me
i'll recreate the stabbing i know it's
been very traumatic it's affected your
entire adult life maybe if we can
recreate it you can ponder it think
about what happened see it really isn't
that bad
it might you know what i think you need
to do dad
i think we need to go to a dodger game
and you need to hit the beach ball
we're going to bring a beach ball and
you're going to launch it into the crowd
because you're the one with trauma and
we'll see what happens you're the one
with trauma dude you're the one that
needs healing
okay oh ethan it was too funny
it's not funny you enable him
afterwards and it was was
he was expressing how he felt about what
dad did and honestly
i think if dad had been a younger man
they might have gone to blows but the
guy looked at dad and said ah this is an
old man someone will accuse me of elder
abuse or something okay what happened
dad so who's this guy that came up to
you well let's just let mom tell the
story go ahead donna go ahead and finish
it up
i i don't know it's like we live in two
different realities sometimes so
this is about you know five minutes
after the the ball has been given back
to the rando
and this uh
uh latino he's an usher now
oh well let's make let's make him an
usher too so this author came up to me
and said
why did you do that no i didn't say he
was oh he's not he wasn't sure yes
okay he wasn't in usher according to
donna
she never she didn't say he was but okay
so he he comes up next to me you know
and i have my seats right on the aisle
um
so he comes and he stands next to me and
he leans over and he goes
you're the guy that punctured the ball i
went yeah he goes why'd you do that
and i explained rationally what did you
say
i said
i've been a dodger game bad dodger fan
for many years i've seen people hit in
the head i've seen drinks knocked over
uh i came here to watch the baseball
game not to watch people hit beach balls
so i'm standing up for the freedom of
people who love baseball who are here to
watch the baseball game and not worry
about getting hit in the head what about
getting hit in the head with an actual
baseball not a volleyball nobody can you
don't get hurt from a volleyball dad
it's a volleyball it floats well
that's what that's what he said
filled with it bro okay well yeah a
volleyball is filled with air too but
you get spiked in the face with that
it's a lot heavier dude how are you
going to bear a volleyball to a beach
ball
okay well uh if
if your brother sean was here he could
explain force and velocity and
everything and explain sure
yeah i'm sure beach balls that weigh
like a quarter of a pound are shot out
of a cannon at 200 miles per hour
if you get hit in the face with it it's
gonna hurt you dude can i have a
question okay so finish the story about
the confrontation
so uh
yeah we we talked for a minute and then
once he understood where i was coming
from he seemed to calm down
and uh went okay and just turned around
and went back to his seat
mom what happened
that's what happened the young man came
over and talked to dad you already had
dad wait i want her version
calm down gary now mom mom is going to
steal my joke that i told her earlier
about him looking at me and saying well
uh do i want to punch this guy or do i
want to get arrested for elder abuse you
know so
so it was my joke that she took because
she didn't even know there was elder
abuse but please i'm pretty sure that's
what you do to her
please governor continue
all right mom go ahead what's your what
actually happened
from the time that the guy came over to
dad
yes yes tell me about the confrontation
and then we left a young guy came over
oh my god wait how are you already what
did she [ __ ] up now
just telling the whole thing all over
again i want to hear this k i want to
hear the story
dang it
all right go ahead mom
god came over to your father
and
he was talking to him and he wanted to
know like dad said if he in fact was the
guy that deflated the beach ball dad
honed up to it and said he did and why
he did it and
and i mean nothing no one came to blows
but i i really think that um
i really think that if dad had been a
younger man
you know it might have been
confrontational right he's going to get
kicked out of the ballpark for life for
coming in hitting some guy who punctured
a beach why would he come over to you
because he was being a big man he was
impressing his family was he
scary-looking
and then he got deflated was he
scary-looking mom
no he wasn't a guy that was
you know he was pretty jacked
we were sitting down so everyone looks
big when you're sitting down of course
so no he was in his late 20s you know
decent shape i guess i don't know he
wasn't in his late 20s he was probably
in his 30s and he was he was fairly all
right so so but don't you see how like
doing this negatively affects the people
you're with like to do that when your
family's there that just seems crazy
dad does not understand
that the whole thing of going to
baseball that it's all a part of the fun
you're going to tell me about going to
baseball dad she's right if you want to
watch the game stay at home
yes on tv
on tv
no no you listen to me now okay
i'm not a kid anymore dad you listen to
me now
damn i'm calm get your hands off me oh
my goodness you guys you're on a show
right now you know that right
you're live on a show
what show
god this segment is tearing this family
apart
okay continue
if you want to watch the show
stay at home you see everything on the
tv every play everything you see it all
okay if you go to a game i'm not done
if you go to a game
there's the social aspect
that that's the whole point you go there
to feel the environment and the
excitement and to be amongst other fans
and that includes [ __ ] like beach balls
and waves and whatever the [ __ ] else and
drunk hooligans and cheering if you
don't want that stay at home
okay i i appreciate that input from
someone who is not a sports fan who's
never like a football game of his own
volition
to someone who has been going to die
people are booing you people are booing
you
i don't care but that means you're wrong
if the majority of people
if the majority of people are booing you
that means that that you're not helping
the greater good which you think you're
serving that's not true i mean you know
people slow down into car crash that
doesn't mean you should slow down in a
car crash okay people like uh excitement
may i continue with my point i've been
going to dodger games since they played
in the coliseum in 1958 i finally able
to get dodger season tickets only
quarter season but still season tickets
i think i know and appreciate that's
enough that's a long trip that's a
logical fallacy that's an appeal to like
uh authority or something it doesn't
mean anything
when baseball the rules of baseball were
established there's no beach balls in
baseball like there's no crying in
baseball okay no crying no beach balls
mom
hold on we need to preserve the family
bring bring back mom
she left
oh god she had to go to yoga class
mom come come back come back we need to
preserve the family
all right let's do a poll is my dad
right or wrong all right stand by now
dad i have a feeling
okay sorry
but there's a lot of tomatoes being
thrown at you right now
now dad we're going to do a poll
[Laughter]
love love thank you for the support
listen they were staying
gary i i don't agree with you but there
is a level of respect for standing your
ground that i must say is very
impressive
dude
i'm sorry but like like we said before
they come on o.j simpson killed people
that's not i'm not i don't respect his
conviction
gary what do you what
how do you think dave robert that was
the problem you know jay was not
convicted yeah and you know oj never
told the jury
bring it on you know what i mean like
bring it on [ __ ] gary gary let me let
me ask you i did it go ahead zach
what's his book i did it
exactly gary gary gary let me how do you
think dave roberts feels about beach
balls i'm just curious no dave hates him
all the ball players hate them when they
i've seen outfielders they have to stop
the game and the outfielder has to go i
guarantee you the players don't care
about beach balls off the field is that
helpful to the flow of the game i don't
think so okay so dad you say you're
serving the greater will
we took a vote of 40 000 people watching
right now
85 say you are wrong
85
okay so that tells me
15
is my math right yes right let me check
with sean 18 and okay yeah you've got 50
of your fans are baseball fans
and and so and so the stadium is full of
people booing you are they not baseball
fans oh my god now the whole stadium is
full of me anyone who witnessed it is
clearly booing you and trying to fight
you
mom said mom only said every single
person
uh except her although she may have been
booing me too i wasn't watching very
clearly say that i said people in our
section were booing you when i was
walking down the stairs i said everyone
anyone who's who could see it i mean
damn i came down the stairs and people
were booing and that's why i said jerry
what did you do
the people in front of me who i talked
to and the people behind me whom i
talked to
none of them were booing someone says i
disagree and i love baseball
let's do a new poll it's it let's do
let's do this is for
baseball fans only say
gary is right gary is wrong and a third
option for i am not a baseball fan okay
so please everyone vote honestly if you
are not a baseball fan
vote the third option i am not a
baseball fan look i'm a die hard dodger
fan as well
i agree with you on this one ethan um
because he's my boss i agree with him
but you agree with me or gary no i agree
with you ethan yeah well of course
you're not a psychopath
[Music]
all right all right new poll
third option
baseball this poll is not for you pick
the third option the integrity of this
poll is very important
so i am not a baseball fan it's option
three
please vote for that one if you want to
vote
anyway the dodgers won and
we got in and out quickly it was awesome
beautiful day
badgers have a great team all all-stars
freddie freeman great addition
absolutely
yes again i were there thursday for the
standing ovation man that was
definitely a great memory i'll have and
everyone there will have forever
they mowed in the number 42
in the graph that was absolutely i saw
that so so what's happening now is i am
not a baseball fan is 60 so that should
let you know that this is a legitimate
pull
gary is right of the remaining
you know 41
33
says gary is wrong eight percent
says gary is right i don't know who
those people are man maybe they're not
honestly it sounds it's roughly the same
percentage as the yeah roughly the same
percentage that's real interesting
it sounds like a fox news poll
yeah
those are angel fairness all right well
i don't know what to say but
he's never wrong
i just find it interesting that after
everything we talked about
on the family's podcast that you're
still out there slamming beach balls
and i'm just glad that people could see
this so they know why i am the way i am
i'm unslamming unslamming beach balls
once you take the air out they can't be
slammed anymore so i'm the unslammer
and i think he came out pretty good i
don't care what anyone else says thanks
to your mother mostly but yeah talk to
my therapist
well
what do they know well yeah right
all right mom any closing words
i i don't know if i'm gonna go to a game
with dad anymore oh boy jessica just did
a cartwheel
yeah i don't know if i can go to a game
with your dad and let the only way i'll
go to a game with you is if we bring a
beach ball and you have to do the
serving hit
i guess you're not going any games this
season you want would you do that if i
got really good seats would you do the
serving hit
i have good seats i wouldn't there's no
seats in the stadium that i would get
over my seats do you see this dad gary's
creed he's got the pens and he's
stomping on the beach
good job whoever did that wait awesome
what if i got like the best well you
probably don't want to do a beach ball
there can we can we as as people want
you to apologize to donna by the way
for what
exactly
people are angry that you slapped her
hand uh out of your face oh no one saw
her pinching the nerve on my neck while
she was standing back in here
rubbing my neck was she was pinching
your your neck okay
no i would not that was the first act of
violence
he was rubbing his shoulders and telling
him to calm down oh yeah you could tell
that i was it was very comfortable okay
anyway where are we so you were refusing
to issue an apology
what's the what's the good apologize
the good apology i believe is if anyone
was offended i apologize yeah that's the
best definitely not the good apology
donna if you were offended i apologize
oh that's horrible terrible that's a
terrible one the offensive
politician defensive i'm sorry they did
yeah it's a politician apology but i
think the people would
be happy if we could go to a game
together and you serve
the uh
the first hit on the beach ball
how about this how about this
i bring a beach ball
you serve the first hit and then if it
comes back to us you can stab it
if we can get on another timeline in the
marvel universe somehow that could
happen
are you saying there's a chance
anyone see the new the trailer for thor
love and thunder yep it looked good oh
my god oh that's going to be so good
i actually saw it on your twitter when
you retweeted it oh awesome yeah with uh
sweet child of mine as the theme
of man taika waititi he's the man yeah
he's great
all right dad you got it
it's your show unfortunately i feel like
you're too old to change at this point
but man
in another part in another parallel
universe you'd be you'd have gone to
therapy when you were 30 and none of
this would be an issue
well that's in your timeline
hey i'm saying there's a timeline
there are what can i do to get you to
serve the beach ball 500 bucks
i cannot be bought
a thousand dollars i was going to say
yeah that's going to get him to go
really high no no for
uh i i don't think i can be bought let
me rephrase that two thousand dollars
no
five thousand dollars to serve a beach
ball
no ethan that's silly i would rather
have you give that money to charity
what about dugout club right behind my
home plate dugout club
um
those
i
that me thinking about it he's thinking
about it
dug up club season tickets let me tell
you let me tell you they got a buffet
it's all you can eat in that dugout club
yeah he's been there i bought him
tickets oh there you go that was for
jessica's birthday actually okay
the food is better than the view but
it's nice they come to your seat and
yeah yeah it's uh it's fancy but
you know i'm up in the lows perfect 10
000
to it you are a charity of your choice
of conveniently the sound cut out
mom you hear that the sound stopped i
think dad conveniently
he hit the mute button
i think you hit the mute button dad
you're muted gary yeah you're muted
you got to hit the mute button on the
phone there i i can still see it your
your microphone's turned off your mic is
turned off dad
it looks like maybe we should keep it on
yeah it seems they carried on without us
oh there you are
there you are
mom you hear that i offered that ten
thousand dollars
to
do to serve a beach ball at dodger
stadium
and i said i will entertain it and give
the money to charity if i decide to do
it and the next and also you have to do
the wave when it comes
no [ __ ] way
[Laughter]
all right
call me back anytime you want to want to
get a lot of laughs on the show so i
have to call my property manager back
all right anything else guys thank you
for your support gentlemen
not support there's not anyone who
supported me love if you want to go to a
dodger game just
come back from sweden you're there
all right thank you thank you jerry
all right guys uh thanks gary all right
take care guys
bye donna bye
bye bye bye love you anyway bye guys see
ya
does that explain something to you guys
i mean this is my life it's not a joke
this is who this is my life god damn it
more than popping the ball the like
thought of him stomping the ball is
hilarious to me but who would do that
like it's funny to you i could only see
you but imagine me 12 year old sitting
next to him i think that chappelle
sketch where rick james is stomping on
eddie murphy's couch [ __ ] your couch
that's the only other
i've seen
i'd be traumatized too
but because everyone's looking at you
and you're the bad guy people come in if
they want to fight you you're 12 years
old you feel like your dad ruined the
game
it's insane
well
it's entertaining for you guys so there
you have it
i'm glad that i could uh
channel my inner deepest childhood
traumas into a fun segment for the show
and truth though as soon as i saw that
video i was like we got to get them on
to talk about it
they both love the attention so they'll
talk about it sure
they really do
yeah you can support my parents they're
both on cameo by the way so
you want my dad to stab a beach ball for
you i'm sure he'd be seven percent in
the audience that voted for him yeah the
gary stands out there he's on cameo
and my mom is too so there you have it
well that was a whole salute that was a
whole activity of calls that was a good
good chunk there yes yes indeed
thank you to our sponsor today nobody
our beautiful members we've had a lot
a lot of new members that's great thank
you guys love our members
we have lost all of our sponsors and i
lost my dad today as well
lost everything i have please become a
member to
help combat people that
that want to write my sponsors anytime
anything happens means a lot and it
really helps
so thank you guys
did you put your dab together with uh
jimmy lee you think that could be dude
i'm just scared of what powerful
i'm scared of what my dad might do or
say
in the company of jimmy lee you know
what i mean that's true yeah be great we
could send them to a dodger game
together
that would be kind of a great special
oh my god
i don't think gary deserves that to be
honest
i don't know i think my dad can deal
with it
i don't think i think he could i think
him and jimmy could get along are james
what's his james wiener well yeah but
jimmy lee nobody can get along with
right because he's just he's on
he's on the warpath how old's your dad
uh
he's like 70 something early 70s all
right i think it would be a good
i think it'd be a good bonding same age
range for sure yeah definitely
jimmy says he's 55 though full [ __ ]
[ __ ]
he swears up and down did he ever send
you his license zach he refuses to send
the license you tell his ass that
there's no redemption unless we see that
license i've tried
and
maybe i shouldn't get into this but
having this set up to do the redemption
has been nothing but
a nightmare well tell me all about it so
he
we were
you know scheduling times and you know
get planning the limo and stuff like
that and he wanted to go out and do like
a full [ __ ] like another eight hour
day and we're like no no no no no no we
are there four hours that is it booked
the limo till then
that's it
moose goodbye and a second longer not
doing it
and he also
refused to
to wear
the outfit we were talking about with
him
he said i have to dress like him
he wants you to dress like him and he
was very [ __ ] adamant but that's that
but that's backwards it's his he needs
to do the whole point is he needs to do
what we're
pitching to him exactly that's what i
kept saying but he because
we gotta have him call in i gotta talk
to him try to get him to call schedule
him as soon as he can to call in
on a monday or wednesday and i gotta
talk to him because i i gotta explain to
him because i want this redemption arc
to happen everybody's primed everybody
wants to see him win
and i i gotta i gotta check in with him
and see how's it going because i feel
like it's going sideways right now well
to his benefit he has been working on
his material okay for the better but
they're still
some things i need to be working on and
like i said i i made it very adamant to
him this is a new jimmy we're going out
with a new giving new jimmy no racism no
whatever
new jimmy
can he be islamophobic
no no right because last time he tried
that and that was shocked us all yeah so
yeah i mean he uh he was very it's
it's his way or the highway even though
we're like this is like our bit yeah and
we had to make sure that it was our crew
only this time
but i imagine the whole thing of like
him wanting to dress a specific way is
because
well it's cool i think no i think he has
some kind of like
if i'm gonna guess and i don't want to
diagnose him but he has some kind of
thing like with the hair yeah and the
suit he needs everything to be a
specific way for him to feel comfortable
which i get it to an extent but this is
our thing he's got to do what we want to
do right so it's um we'll bring them on
maybe we can negotiate we'll we'll
figure it out okay i want to talk to him
all right okay
thank you everybody becoming a member
right now thank you guys so much
and uh apologies for single-handedly
setting back uh gay rights 100 years
yeah after our last podcast it actually
became illegal gay marriage became
illegal again so it was really damaging
so i'm very sorry about that
now it's a good time to join because we
have a good behind the scenes this week
a lot of people in it
eric uh
oh yeah you yeah nice a lot of people
go ahead keep going
main susana xbend uh banks
minks oh minks yeah
a lot of people it's gonna be fun
i don't have anything else to ask you
anything
if you guys want to be part of the h3
community hit that member button we
appreciate every single one of you
please help the show out can i get a woo
we love you we love our members we love
our fans so make sure to hit that
membership button and join the h3 army
hey everybody
thanks for watching h3 podcast it means
a lot if you hit that membership belt
sponsored the show
a lot coming up a lot of work a lot of
ins and outs
thank you so much
coming up next
[Music]
we've got the
painted block
top of the hour it is actually top of
the hour
the the weather is 73 degrees
traffic is mild coming up the 101.
[Music]
all right i guess we better talk about
the title
this ace family scam because this shit's
actually super funny
it's a fun show man
it's all happening we have fun here on
the issue we have a good
in between sending gay rights back uh
thousands of years we have fun
i should stop joking stop saying that
yeah honestly please
we don't do that that's a joke
okay so
somebody so now
not to give away too much but i guess we
did put it in the title uh we we
purchased tickets to ace fest right
correct
we did we were planning on going we kind
of knew
there was a strong chance that
that wouldn't
be happening
i mean oh man this is crazy
so
oh by the way this is kind of comes up
before the ace fest thing we were kept
wondering like
actually i shouldn't show this i don't
want to dox them but
we found out that they're
paying 50 000 a month rental house on
their new house after the foreclosure
that's a lot that is a high monthly
insane they're are they they must still
be making a lot of money i don't know
what's going on i don't know how
but 50 000 a month that's good
right i mean they have fans oh [ __ ]
jimmy can call right now all right bring
him on yeah they're gonna have to do it
jimmy lee detour thank you liam can you
bring me a saudi thank you
all right jimmy lee detour guys can you
send me a zoom linkedin yeah thank you
dan's excited is he in a dark room
or it will be
dude that was the funniest [ __ ] the dark
room transition was so epic
do i need to click that or that's for
jimmy that's for jimmy
all right well yeah um
[ __ ] fifty thousand a month who pays
that in rent that's nuts that is insane
that's six hundred thousand dollars a
year
just in just in rent that's crazy
well i mean at this point
you have to imagine
um they can't they don't have credit
like they can't get a new house or
anything um
even if they have cash right they can't
get a mortgage at this point
but then how can they have but so i'm
wondering they thank you lena
they need their house to look insane
otherwise like if they're just living in
like a little condo everyone's gonna be
like right that's yeah
okay well anyway um where is the it's at
the top the top right
so the the thing is about the
ace family
is that they are basically proven this
comes from deaf noodles
who was
um
who's this guy
mad madcaster did this incredible
investigating who by the way
when i saw this i was like this guy
looks familiar like i feel like i've
seen this guy's videos before and i i
realized
like a month or two ago i wat he did a
deep dive on your lawsuits with ryan
cavanaugh and i actually watched it and
and really liked what he had to say
about it yeah so he's uh shut up
madcaster yes
love that someone said whoever bought
these tickets are clowns uh hello that's
us oops
well we knew we knew yeah it was a
strong chance
yeah
well to be honest we don't know what
if it's cancelled if it's a scam or
what's
exactly their plan is
but i'll let uh madcaster explain it's
on sale and now i'm going to put a
couple of things up here and i want to
thank my friend who sent me these wants
to remain anonymous here's the evidence
okay so tickets went on sale i think it
was like nine o'clock so at 9 22 not
long after tickets went on sale my
friend took screenshots you went on to
the ace family fest website did you guys
buy tickets like right away how fast
yeah yeah we bought them
as soon as they dropped yeah
an ace family posted on their website
it's all sold out
yeah there's a link to their website if
you want to go there and how long after
the tickets went on put the tickets on
sale and now i'm going to put a couple
of things up here and i want to think
it's one on sale like a week or two ago
and it only quote unquote sold out uh
within the last week right within the
last few days even
uh i'm pretty sure that it said it sold
out the that night that they weren't
well i think it was the same day yeah oh
really okay so
he has basically really good evidence
that they're lying about it being sold
out and i don't know what they're
getting at by saying it's sold out
like i wonder
well in their video when they were
promoting it they were telling all their
fans like for sure it's going to sell
out right away they were emphasizing on
that a lot right but like if you don't
sell tickets what yeah i know i'm just
saying another thing to consider yeah i
don't know one theory i have is maybe
they're going to try to put them on the
aftermarket
and then build like artificial hair
they're going to flip their own tickets
yeah actually artists do that that's
crazy maybe insane i've heard that a lot
of artists flip their own tickets holy
[ __ ] except that's when there's actually
demand right
that's interesting
there was a huge scandal about
this huge band maybe you can fact check
the city
they sold out this huge stadium
immediately
and someone investigated and found out
they only sent sold like 10 of the
available tickets and flipped the other
80 in the aftermarket huh
yeah i mean
i need that clout
it's crazy
oh i i think it's metallica right oh
okay yeah metallica metallica did that
but it's a common practice i think
yeah so much for the fans right just
money
just money machines
man
oh what is this a leaked recording of a
phone call between a consultant who
works with metallica in live nation
reveals what's long been talked about
behind closed doors that the promotion
giant live nation which also owns
ticketmaster teams up with artists to
resell their own tickets for a higher
price on the secondary market through
backdoor deals that sounds like exactly
what you just described
wow that's [ __ ] but i don't think
there's the same there's no demand
clearly for that for what they're trying
to do yeah they're not mentally this is
me
well we'll see if a bunch of tickets go
up in resale in fact are there can you
find any ace fest tickets right now
actually that's what we do
i don't think anyone's looking for that
okay let's watch our boy here wants to
remain anonymous here's the evidence
okay so tickets when i sale i think it
was like nine o'clock so at 9 22 not
long after tickets went on sale my
friend took screenshots she went on to
the ace family fest website and at that
point the tickets were still on sale and
she's so freaking clever and i just want
to thank her so much for being so smart
what she did was she took the shopping
basket for the two different type they
have the two passes they have the one
for 299 that i think was for three
people and then the one for 4.99 which i
think was for five people and she put
one million tickets into the basket now
what happens with the shopping cart is
if there isn't the number of items that
you're trying to buy
it will automatically reduce your cart
number
down to what is actually available okay
so that's important to put the tickets
on ticket and what it showed her was for
the 499
pass the family vip pass there were only
thousand nine hundred oh [ __ ] mad
casters in the chat what's up player
what's up playing
oh wait it's mad cat cat cat still mad
catster okay
what's up
player mad cat stir in the chat what's
up what's up what's up what's up what's
up what's up player and thank you for
covering the the lawsuit by the way i i
yeah i watched your video uh i think it
was about a month ago it was great
thank you very much for that nice
coverage
it's available at 9 22. so the
speculation that we have is that there
were probably to start 8 000 tickets on
sale in that category so at 9 22 we're
at 79.04 a minute later at 9 23 she went
to the 299 pass that was available and
she again put in a million tickets and
look at this is what it showed so it
reduced the number down to 3977
which means that we speculate there
probably were 4 000 of those asses
available so a total of 12 000 passes in
total even though
guys i gotta i gotta go the bathroom
just like that
no warning
in reality you got scammed
well but
[Music]
don't you want to watch it
[Music]
all right well uh hey everybody
uh the role of a lifetime again how's
your weekend
my weekend was good i went to a wedding
on saturday with the girl and uh it was
a great time
uh oh yeah um i ran into a fan actually
at uh we went to the casino afterwards
bachanga casino resort in
temecula california nice um we all
agreed i was there this wedding it was
with a group of friends that i grew up
with
and we were all laughing about the fact
that the pechanga was down the street
because if you grew up in la you know or
anywhere in southern california pretty
much every other
ad on the radio is for pechanga casino
and resort it's just a non-stop barrage
and um
and we realized we were like 10 minutes
away we're like [ __ ] we gotta go to
pechanga this is our chance so we went
there and i ran into a fan i think her
name was ryan i hope i got your name
right but if you're watching ryan shout
out it's nice to shout out
um
and then yeah we did uh
did the easter up at my up at ma's house
the next day so yeah how about yours oh
you did the um stream on saturday yeah i
was on i spent stream it was really cool
it was a lot of fun
uh i mean idubbbz were doing like
sparring drills and we were about to
actually spar but then like the place we
were at told us we couldn't spar
so i
kind of looked like we were just kind of
poking each other like grandpas before
they cut it but uh yeah it was a lot of
fun it was really cool
met eric uh front of the show comment
etiquette
big money soviet
[Music]
do you smoke salvia uh he didn't no not
that i saw damn and i met uh minks who
was hilarious uh
she was like beating the [ __ ] out of uh
sven there's a bunch of clips of it
already
she's so funny yeah it was a good time
i've seen quite a few people saying they
watched and it was a good great stream
that's cool yeah i was watching and the
and the family was definitely in the
chat i saw family spam all the time yeah
well they were shouting about the
burrito too right there yeah yeah it's
really cool i always feel like i'm like
the least significant person there
because i like these big streamers and
youtubers but yeah the family was strong
people were spamming about my burrito to
the point that i had to explain the
significance of the legendary burrito
good job good job everybody trolling him
with that gg guys gg
uh
somebody just threw 50 bucks canadian at
us said in isolation right now meaning i
can finally watch the show live i'm
assuming
that's a covid related thing i i hope
you're okay
uh usually work from the show goes live
i'm blessed for peace and love hope you
all stay safe you too you too hidden
ghost one two one stay safe out there
stay safe well my weekend i had the
worst passover i didn't
we're just talking ask just throwing
throwing in what we're talking about you
know just [ __ ] around guys i wanted
to share this i'm [ __ ] around go
ahead the worst passover seder in my
[ __ ] life
how how what was what was wrong with it
just the company dude it was dog [ __ ]
you mean your family yeah
i'm sorry to hear that buddy it wasn't
like my parents or grandmother i failed
yeah
yeah
actually
if i could plug something something's
coming up on the 30th
very important show plug it i mean our
boss is in the bathroom so
what the hell we want dan can i plug it
uh you talking about your show yeah of
course you could plug it hell yeah april
april 30th live at the mint
links on my story
live at the main gonna be a kick-ass
show
check it out it's gonna be clever what
are you talking about i wish i could
call i'm playing some tunes there you
use my band
and um
zach lewis live with the mint it's going
down some of us will be there i'll be
there to support my boy of course yeah
and i'm looking forward to seeing a lot
of you beautiful people i appreciate
that yeah we'll play some kick ass tunes
some original some covers and uh playing
an hour slot
yeah we're headlining how much an hour
slot yeah yeah what's that how long were
you going last time last time it was
only like a 30 minute set there's no
okay they saw like wow like this yeah
you had the whole place like sold out
out the door yeah
i felt kind of bad after you left i feel
like the place cleared out
well that's why he's the headliner this
time oh hell yeah they they got that
yeah
well i think they were caught off guard
yeah
when they booked him
that uh zach was gonna
sell out uh there's something on your
face apparently zach yeah that's what
ian was telling okay
[Music]
you know my [ __ ] beard is like
getting
your own beard bruh i threw a quick eye
on the reddit and it's of course a
cesspool like usual but i saw like 10
posts about me saying jalapeno
yeah yeah with that well i wasn't going
to correct you because you know i know
you have a love of saying ninja language
ninja so you go so the j
in spanish is pronounced like an h in
english so it's like jalapeno not
jalapeno jalapeno
okay sweetie we say yellow
that's actually well that's closer
you should just say the way you say it
in swedish because that that was closer
to the real pronunciation so love how
would you say zach lewis live at the
mint
zach lewis live at the mint there you go
he's like let's not move on from this
plug
[Laughter]
love you uh you missing cam
yeah i miss all of you guys
well actually
we miss you we really do you brought a
lot of joy to the audience you i mean to
the office you kept us young
by the way jimmy lee's been on hold in
[ __ ] lobby for the last like 15
minutes yeah so sorry honestly very
bored in sweden like extremely bored i
don't know imagine
i feel for cam how you feeling cam you
feeling lonely now without love
hello can you hear me yeah yeah
yeah i miss i miss love a lot but we've
been we've been uh streaming on tick
tock being goofy goobers on the uh
tick tock lives there
chica talks
and uh
love eats mcdonald's in his car it's a
blast it's a lot funner than what i
described but
it's been fun yeah and uh
i know we'll hang out again with love
soon
every time you guys say that like you
guys say soon
people think like soon soon but
whatever's gonna happen it's gonna be
like a while a good while just so you
guys know we'll see you again we'll see
you eventually eventually yeah
i love how cam is the bunny
yeah like the first time i i don't know
if ian just zoomed into him or why but
it looked like
he was mad
it would bug me when cam would talk and
i just would have to leave it like this
yeah yeah that's the only available
characters right here it works perfect i
love being the bunny
embrace embrace the bunny
cam
the bunny grant
how you doing ian
what are you afraid of man what are you
ian what are you afraid of
we can't stop saying that
yeah
like it's
it's a borderline obsession at this
point
what are you afraid of ian like oh that
was
yeah energetically dude
you know you want to try that again
go ahead what are you afraid of ian
beautiful
you know we always see comments like
people saying that they have sound bites
stuck in their head and it's so annoying
because there's no one to talk to about
us you know because maybe not all their
friends watch the show or whatever but
when you're surrounded around like five
or six people always say sound bites
they're so catchy but for some reason
the ian sound bites always stick at
least
i think because he gets so annoyed with
it there's like something in our brain
that just like yeah i don't know we've
been saying all week like what are you
afraid of being here what are you afraid
of he hasn't said anything
for some reason every few months zach
picks a thing to just terrorize me with
and that that's really how the sound
bites started the first sound bite ever
i believe was like i got a piece so bad
right not legendary one of them and then
we had you know the stand up you got to
terrorize me with and then i feel like
there was another one i'm missing i'm
not sure yeah it's the clapton's cheeks
see but they're i think they're so
legendary because you say so few
so i feel like they they i've started to
whisper it to him now
what are you afraid of oh yeah that's
that's zach was doing that this morning
was cracking me up because it was so
quiet so faint
what are you afraid i'm afraid of the
sound bite yeah what are you afraid of
there it is
so thank you rolo tony browntown for
saying ethan's name wrong
legendary soundbite uh grace donated
said uh donated earlier can you say
happy birthday while ethan is taking his
[ __ ] absolutely happy birthday grace
happy birthday happy birthday great
birthday
matt said ian thoughts
ian thoughts what are you afraid of ian
are you afraid what are you afraid of
ian are you afraid of ian what are you
afraid of ian
there's something on your face zach what
happened
it's been handled a little fluff for
[ __ ] i don't know oh you know what what
it probably was some kebab sauce ah
perhaps so um ethan uh
i don't know if you want to jump back
into ace family thing jimmy's been
waiting in the waiting room for like 20
minutes now okay so so let's just kind
of feel bad no let's bring out jimmy
we'll do that and then and then we'll
get back to the ace family okay all
right stand by i'm gonna bring him in
sorry guys it's just
you know what it was is i had spicy
mexican food last night and i just have
to stop i can't do it yeah i think
unfortunately it's just it's sad it's
sad to
it's tragic in my life that
that's literally why we were late today
too starting
i woke up i was on time i was like i was
great
i just it's so hard it's like what i
love
i don't i love mexican spicy mexican
food so i mean i get it but i go crazy
i bought like a third
spicy mexican food last night just give
me mute your streams jimmy can you uh
pop off that stream oh i was hearing
myself yeah jimbo
jimmy
hello
loving that uh
i got a new hairdo oh she's gonna say
loving the uh i was like
what am i hearing wait hold on give me
mute your
what is that look it's like
that's james weiner right it's the no
it's the chairman chi
and chairman mao chairman
it's giving turtle the train kung fu
panda
he still can't figure out how to mute
the stream we love that for him
he baptized himself
yeah he's actually muted on the zoom now
okay you muted yourself there right
how about now bright eyes all right
let's get better much better yeah i
think we're good
now hello guys what's this look you're
going for i like it
well zach wants me to sport a new look
so i'm doing the the telly survivalist
look today
which is kojak he was a tv show when i
was young
and uh zach said to me today my talent
outside my head so i wanted to thank
zach for that
okay i i'm sure
some of the references went over my head
but
the delivery was good
but uh
things are going good things are things
are going good
and we're looking forward to our shoot
with you guys may 17th jimmy may
something do the glasses sit naturally
that high on your head or do they go
down just curious
how's that that looks yeah that looks
bad more more
correct is that better like that no
it is okay
so i understand what i just wanted to
get you on the phone
to talk a little bit because zach
talking to zach it sounded like it was
going sideways a little bit you were
making demands on us and i just wanted
to make sure that this this redemption
tour is going to go the right way
because i would hate
to see uh
i would hate to see it go sideways so
zach do you want to voice some of your
concerns to jimmy and then and then kind
of let's let's take it from there and i
can hopefully mediate yeah yeah yeah um
well the first and foremost was the
outfit
you were pretty adamant that you didn't
want to dress like me
so we compromised and i was just curious
why
why you were so like
set in stone on dressing like you like
you want zach to dress like you you are
unwilling to come in a hawaiian shirt
and shorts and do all that like zach
right
not short no we
no we compromised ethan where i'm going
to do the hawaiian shirt but he said i
can wear the black leather coat right
and they're black pants so it's kind of
jimmy lee with a hawaiian shirt i guess
i'm used to my outfit
you know it's kind of an odd look the
the hawaiian shirt with the black jacket
it just doesn't seem right i mean zach
rocks it yeah i wear it all right
okay yeah okay
um so there was that but i was just
curious like what was the hesitation
with that like do you not like my look
like am i not stubborn oh no
you zach looked phenomenal you looked
like a storm when we were walking around
by the kimmel show and all that i think
i'm just used to wearing my own costume
i guess i'm used to my
leather coat glasses because i've been
doing it so long oh you get older you
don't like changing that much i haven't
changed i haven't changed ethan in 40
years which is a big savings on my
laundry
right
good yeah that's true that is a good
savings
but i think part of this experiment is
to
is to i think to change you right to put
you out of your comfort zone to reinvent
jimmy the outlaw into jimmy the
upstanding citizen so it needs to be
a catatonic shift
if you would please
so you want me to look totally like do a
180 is what you want me i think so yeah
well you know my my outfit is not
drastically different
than his necessarily like i always wear
a leather jacket and like jeans or dark
pants or something but i like always
rock a hawaiian shirt and he just seemed
very against that when we were talking
but though we did reach a compromise no
we i said i would wear and then zach
said you can wear the black leather coat
so i called fonzie from happy days uh
ian and i got him to give me the coat so
i got fonzie's coat i think i'm happy i
think what would be interesting is if
you can dress like zach that's funny but
if you want to pitch a new outfit i'm
open to that too but i think we need to
leave jimmy jimmy lee
the jersey outlaw in the past and move
forward like the phoenix rising from the
ashes
so we need to tell you what new house
you want a different outfit then
i think so yeah
all right so zach should we talk another
time figure it out i mean we got a
couple weeks but you seem open-minded so
that's good exactly yeah
was there any other issues zack you
wanted to resolve oh the the limo time i
mean we we told you we're going like
four hours
right so i had said to zach they have
because they have a lot of problems they
have a six-hour minimum so i said i'm
gonna have the limit for six i'm paying
and i said when you can do zach four you
can do five and whatever you guys decide
is fine
let's see you know fair share okay yeah
okay yeah okay mm-hmm but other so i
i figured eleven o'clock we have it
eleven to five and if zach's had enough
of me by three i i have the limo for
another hour or two for me does that
seem fair zach yeah what are you gonna
do for that other hour though
ethan agreed if i'm play nice he may
come out for the day and drive me in the
rolls so we may do that at the end which
i thought i never said that
that's definitely
ian and i are going to twist ian's arm
and and and if we're nice ethan may come
out we may get him to come out what's
that
twisty
well twist the arm a little bit you know
you get a couple of security guards to
work you over in the back seat and then
maybe you'll come out what does that
mean jimmy i'm confused
well you ever you hear that ever hear
the mafia
i heard the mafia yeah
well you know you know what they do when
you don't do what they want they twist
your arm a little bit they shoot your
uncle oh oh you know okay
you're gonna kill my uncle that's fine
no no you you but i tell you i got a
friend
i got a friend ethan in a mafia he's got
a very very fancy core he has a hood
under the hood
it's got a hood can you explain that one
i'd like a hood like a
body the hood
you're all hood you know the mafia is
the hood the hood under the hood
i don't know if i've never associated
the hood with the mafia
do you
i i honestly quite frankly now quite
frankly i know zach says so
the the other issue was i guess it
wasn't an issue it was more that we're
hoping you're working on new material
which you've been sending me stuff
oh yeah and i've been working on a lot
of self-deprecating jokes and i've been
working on if you watch the circus thing
i did the disco there's self-deprecation
there and i have a lot of general jokes
when i was friends with marty and steve
and i have all those jokes ready to roll
they're all clean clean jokes dude hit
me with it if you want to try some on me
let's let's get yeah well well i i was
asked and zach zach knows because he
made the phone call i got a call from
readers digest ethan they asked me last
week to be the centerfold for reader's
digest but i don't like where they put
those damn staples
i told ian i'm not going to do it
you don't like where they put the
staples because because then it will if
he's in the center then the staples will
be in his crotch region
very good i got it i got it i got it all
right
oh all right
wait why don't you want the staple over
your crush so that your crotch is
visible
no because it would hurt it would hurt
to have a staple in in oh they're gonna
actually staple your body right yeah
yeah right but the staples are
physically there they they're not
actually there in the photo shoot right
that's that's part of that's part of the
joke jimmy you just thought of the joke
yeah
jimmy i got another question
you keep sending me this picture of this
one guy is that any claim that's your
manager is that really your manager is
that just you and a wig jimmy
what photo did i say when you were in
atlantic city
oh me and my friend were in a limo we
rocked the nuts and my other buddy took
some pictures the limo guy is a friend
and he he took some pictures in the limo
and we're acting crazy so uh mason my
social media guy he tagged it uh two
wild and crazy guys so i sent you some
of the pictures with the imagery and and
the uh
and the uh
you know some of the text lines we're
coming up with you know like work with
me bingo
uh you know we're just coming up with uh
different tag lines so to speak okay
just try to be catchy hey jimmy did you
notice there was like a great moment in
our last talk where the room got
gradually darker
and it was like a big hit with our fans
did you see that yeah
maybe turn off the office light and we
can relive the magic oh you want the
magic
so ethan guess what
sure i i'm so screwed up and every time
i masturbate i get a headache
now it's too dark
[Laughter]
guess what when you go to the drive-in
movie you can watch it right here i got
a five-head not a forehead
so you know
what now you said you you get a headache
every time you masturbate every time i
masturbate now i get a headache
yeah
does anyone get that
last night in i had a glass of prune
juice and took two viagra i don't know
if i'm coming or going i'm having a
rough time that one i get yeah that's
funny that's pretty good but what's the
headache one
well
do you ever masturbate and get a
headache it's a joke
no not a funny joke that's why it's
funny because it doesn't happen but i
gotta tell you what
it's stupid
and by the way i wanted i have a funny
joke off the coffee and i want to tell
you i wonder if i if you have time when
i come out i want to take you to the zoo
so your real parents can claim you
okay that's good
is that okay yeah it's funny for me but
not great for the on the street i would
say
right and ian uh i i talked to your
father i told him keep the picture that
comes with the wallet
give the picture
because he opened up his wallet you know
how people have pictures of the kids in
the wallet
why is ian getting roasted right now no
watch watch going dork
wait a minute jimmy lee in the dark oh
guess what happened to me last week at
the disco zach
the disco
i got picked up by two chinese girls one
gave me a saturday night fever and the
other gave me a sunday morning rash was
a rough night yes so that one's probably
not the best to take on the road
we're not taking that one home yeah the
whole chinese i feel like the joke can
work but the throwing in the chinese
girl part is you know that makes people
uncomfortable it makes people
uncomfortable yeah there was also
another one in in one of the videos you
said uh
i forget the joke but the punchline was
come quick
they just seemed kind of wrong
my wife told me my chinese name last
night come quick
[Laughter]
my wife's afraid oh my god my wife's
afraid his wife is chinese
right and my wife's afraid of the dog
she saw me naked now she's afraid of the
light you think it's easy that's good i
like that joke
she wants to have sex in the backseat of
the quarry and she wants me to drive i'm
having a rough time with her right now
that's a good one i think we heard that
with me zach zach work with me also work
with me people bingo
bingo
bingo
[Applause]
are we keeping the catchphrases are we
doing something new
uh i honestly zach i have to say
something interesting there were a lot
of comments
and a lot of them complimented you and
me being together they said
you know we were like a good team and
you you looked like a star zack the way
you were dressed and how you carry
yourself because you're bigger than me
and when you walked around i was
watching and it was like a good little
vibe it really was i'm sorry i don't
even interrupt but jimmy you kind of
look like neil right now
it looks like you're in the matrix it's
there's like a green tint
causing a lens flare
just kidding
there you go oh
time having a rough time when i was a
kid i wanted to play tag my dad my dad
drove a car to find me
wait is this what you're seeing because
i don't see this hold on this is what
you guys are saying
i have normal color here no i see you
just fine is that how you see it yeah
yeah i don't know
maybe it's like one of those
what do you think of my glasses
what do you think of my glasses ethan
they're great
do you think i'm making a spectacle
myself oh you gotta you gotta cut that
one that one that one is just we counted
you said that like 30 times in 2022 the
whole spectacle stick
no good working no no
uh i'm having a rough time all right
you got one more go ahead one more
you want another joke
a clean one fresh one whatever you got
well i got a really a really fresh one i
don't know if you want to hear it i
think zach knows it
are you ready
yeah
i went to a meeting for premature
ejaculators last night now i went ethan
i came early but i was there
right
no no good you didn't like it i think it
should be more like i came early and
left
i came early but i was there or maybe
that's fine the come came early i came
early but i left i came early but and uh
no one i came early
came early had a good time no one else
was satisfied though oh there you go
yeah yeah there there
that's actually not very good
well thank you
what do you think ethan to the arab joke
last time i thought personally i liked
it
i mean it was funny but not for the
right reason right
not for the right reasons okay i think
we were all just shocked that
that was your attempt at a clean joe
because it was like clearly
racist
well guess what happened today in my
dental office you want to hear a weird
thing sure
two of two egyptian people came in and
they parked their camel right in the
front of my store
that's not a joke
no it's a true two camels
he's my cousin and i walked outside i
said get off the hump your mother get
off the hump
is that well that really happened
yeah zach was there
yeah that's really not a joke as much as
it's just like an anecdote
i believe it i have a camel outside
right now
av travels by camel
are you serious yeah yeah yeah that's
serious i think i think you're in denial
oh
see that that was clever
yeah
actually this is really interesting
jimmy you ever consider
would you consider
what am i doing can you see this down or
no uh if you put it uh
yeah he's seeing it right now yeah yeah
would you ever consider uh
doing playing neo in a matrix remake
sure if zach wants me to do it i do
whatever zach tells me to do if he tells
me to jump off a building i'm going to
tell him not again jimmy i got one more
thing i got to call you out on and and
you're real you posted you caught out
like the best part
of the video
oh i know what you're going to say when
i said where's the audio yeah yeah here
i have it i want to check audio audio
audio video audio oh yeah i never asked
you about that because everyone was so
hyped to get out and then the minute you
came out you started obsessing over the
audio what happened there
so my my video guy says i just paused
the whole star feeling and he said you
got to lift it up
and i said you're right but you're wrong
it's funny to leave it in he says oh you
got to take it out because you had cool
music and then all of a sudden the fans
were there and to pause it and stop that
that vibe he didn't like it so we lifted
it out i'm not saying you're wrong
because it was funny when i came out and
the whole vibe went when
audio
and
i
said
audio audio
uh so so next time would you do the
audio stick or will you try to avoid no
i i probably keep the key
because it's funny yeah okay no i keep
it in because it's funny
right so you would do it again
yeah i didn't tell you about my
girlfriend did i tell you about my
girlfriend's ian
yeah ian did he talk thoughts in
uh
well i got a new girlfriend and she's 29
years old she's spanish she's a gorgeous
lovely lady my wife don't care for her
sure right yeah i can understand because
that makes sense your wife would be
upset that you had a girlfriend yeah
that makes sense
okay well it seems like we're on the
right track there's a good compromise
happening so we're gonna this the uh
redemption arc is still on mm-hmm
okay so i'm doing i'm doing how you guys
want it i already know the kind of
material you want i'm all good i'm all
good right it's going to be done you
know nice and clean so we don't get beat
up or thrown out or whatever that's good
that's good because i was worried about
that at times
yeah why do you keep putting me in green
i think there's something wrong i
apologize
do you hate the jersey outlaw that much
ian that you got to put me in green
yeah yeah
what are you afraid of man ian ian it
was normal on my end i don't see
anything yeah it looks normal
all right jimmy i gotta let you go
all right get ready wait a minute you're
gonna let me go but watch it watch ethan
oh
we're back oh
[Laughter]
here's oliver tree in the jersey outlaw
signing off there it is
all right you take care of this
thanksgiving all right looking forward
to uh
to the next uh collab there all right
after yeah thanks for having me on guys
love you all right i love you too buddy
bye bye all right see you
there it is jimmy lee the jersey outlaw
oh my god
it's funny i've seen people saying ethan
ruined pesto for me forever
i find that funny i'm sorry i just do
there was one meme cam sent of him next
to colonel kurtz from apocalypse now
yeah that was [ __ ] amazing i was
trying to think what i was
yeah that's what i was referencing not
the godfather marlon brandon
right right actor wrong wait a pocket he
has apocalypse now look oh that's
[Music]
that's interesting the lighting is very
similar that was great cam
[Laughter]
oh my god wow
all right well back to uh ace family we
were
just talking
with uh good luck with the highlights
by the way
i was just wishing love luck with the
highlights he's gonna have to yeah
you're gonna have to do something
i'm used to it don't worry yeah
here we go what it showed her was for
the
499
pass the family vip pass there were only
seven thousand nine hundred and four
tickets available at 9 22. so the
speculation that we have is that there
were probably to start 8 000 tickets on
sale in that category so at 9 22 we're
at 79.04 a minute later at 9 23 she went
to the 299 pass that was available and
she again put in a million tickets and
look at this is what [ __ ] showed so it
reduced the number down to 3977
which means that we speculate there
probably were 4 000 of those asses
available so total of 12 000 passes in
total even though you'll see here i'm
going to put this up where they say
there's only 5 000 tickets available
well clearly not there they put on more
than that but this is where it gets
really sad okay so then my friend went
ticket and what it showed her was for
the 499
pass the family vip pass there were only
7 904 tickets available at 9 22. so the
speculation that we have is that there
were probably to start 8 000 tickets on
sale in that category so at 9 22 we're
at
79.04 a minute later at 9 23 she went to
the 299 pass that was available right
especially then put in just before
the tickets were marked and sold out
because they went and put in on their
thing that it was sold out at 5 27 p.m
so now this is a full what eight hours
later she went on to the website and in
the cart again she put in for the
million tickets and what came up was for
the family vip pass for 4.99 at that
time at 5 27 in the evening there were 7
598 tickets available you can see that
here and for the ace family club pass
there were 3
890 tickets still available so what does
this mean well in eight hours of tickets
being on sale this is what my
calculations show so between 9 22 a.m
and 5 27 p.m for the ace family vip pass
the 499 dollar ticket they sold a total
of
306 passes just before the tickets were
that was good six passes
in eight hours and for the 299 dollar
family club pass between 9 23 a.m and 5
27 p.m they sold a grand total
if you go by what we figured the
starting inventory was on both of those
passes that means in in the whole time
that tickets were on sale the ace family
sold
110
total
passes for the 299 family club pass and
402 total passes for the 499 family vip
pass that's pretty pathetic don't you
think like hardly a seller can you do
the numbers on that because i don't
think he calculated it or at least
um
def didn't include it
but he said it was like 400 at 500 bucks
right and 100 at 299 right
230k
wait seriously
well i mean yeah that's pretty good 500
apiece i mean it's expensive i mean it's
all clearly not enough to put on a
festival by any means
that's enough to get a couple goats and
a like a trampoline or pay for four
months of rent
right right totally
yeah that's crazy that if they steal all
that money and do nothing that what they
can do is pay for four months of rent
well we don't know if they've stolen it
yet i mean the event might be happening
but it's going to be two goats and a
trampoline right and like and like a uh
popcorn machine that you can rent for
the day well there was there was only
ever kind of vague allusions to what the
event would consist of right um no they
were just usually kind of like stock
images of of generic carnival activity
let me read the website again because i
can tell you
they have generated 200 000
and they need to host
there was there was uh uh
300 times five that's 1500 people right
was that the numbers
it was four hundred four hundred times
five hundred two thousand people right
they need to and then there was three
times a hundred
so another three so 30
23 000 people they need the host
right
yes yes i just need a little excitement
in my life they gotta host 23 000 people
so let's get the intel again
there is no way why would they do that
did you find any aftermarket [ __ ] no i
didn't i looked everywhere
so i wonder if they can't they're like
we didn't sell enough we need to cancel
this i think i wonder if they're going
to refund everyone
because they're probably like there's no
[ __ ] way this is happening we didn't
sell enough tickets
that's enough to flee the country well
something uh another detail um i don't
know if you're aware of ethan is that um
when sam bought the tickets you know put
in the credit card info and everything
and bought it
um
there
no tickets were sent oh no [ __ ] there's
no like
was there even like a confirmation email
sam
uh she said that she got like a receipt
oh all we got was a receipt we got a
receipt what if they're
of the tickets and they didn't ask for
shipping address or anything so um
yeah it's only 2 300. yeah when you said
that i was like yeah okay guys i was
trying to figure out 200 tickets
the receipt was also just like an auto
response from shopify or whatever right
like whatever so there's no information
they've never sent you an email anything
no i don't know anything like how we're
getting the tickets
uh it showed a picture of like a
physical pass on the website but i
didn't have to put in a shipping address
so that's interesting right
so they're selling merch i love they're
selling merch to the event
oh we gotta pick some of that up what
does it say one last ride one last round
one last ride
so so basically it was a shopify front
or was a receipt from shopify saying you
bought something from the ace family
right but no official email from them no
it was just like an auto email that is
very concerning it's a little concerning
yes
yeah but then now we bought it as a meme
because we wanted to be there to report
but i just don't know how people
genuinely supporting them that that that
to me is insane i mean this is how i
think how are people still buying nfts
it's the same people
well i mean
i i am a little surprised that they
didn't sell more than that because i'm
not well we've talked extensively about
you know all of the shady dealings but i
i mean but they're like the boxing
eventually put on was such a disaster
yeah and they've been they've just
they've scammed people so many times
they're fans the ace club in reality you
guys got scammed he literally said that
to his fans right
he sure did
so let's see the ace you guys got
scammed
it's a hundred dollars per pr per ticket
which is like
as much almost as disneyland
right which yeah i mean
it's not
it's no disneyland that's for sure well
let's see what they promised the ace
fest is a one-day festival
um
ace fest has a variety of free games
free rides and free prizes
as well as free access to wildlife
animals and live performances bro i
cannot
what what i'm telling you'll be one goat
i mean wildlife does that just mean like
the coyotes that are like wandering
around life even mean
you know there's not gonna be any
wildlife there's gonna be domesticated
animals
there's some pigeons around seagulls you
know breaking up lots of birds yeah
that's wildlife
that's true technically
pigeons
think of this festival as the ultimate
family playground
so you're right it is pretty vague but
what they promise here is already way
free games free rides free prizes i
guess if they really
go like if there's one [ __ ] claw game
uh one
uh what could be a free ride at that
budget
well typical carnival stuff i'm sure you
know ferris wheel and you know that kind
of stuff pretty exciting you've been to
those kind of like
you know
well that's true usually those are
coming out
and they're there for months right the
one that the kind of carnival i'm
describing is that cost a hundred
dollars to go to so this man is doing
this for one day
yeah
[Music]
i i either this there's only one
possibility
i guess there's two possibilities three
really
one is that they realized they didn't
sell enough tickets and it's just a
total disaster so they're going to
refund people they'll probably make up
an excuse like
uh is something happen
it's someone we were working with
someone did something people were
working with really screwed us or if
something came up then we can't do it
you know there'll be some kind of
um excuse
to cancel the event
the other one the other possibilities
that they're going to try to sell these
in the aftermarket which i don't get
because there's no demand
right when
yeah because according to the the kind
of investigation that uh mad catster did
uh on there
when they set up the shopify you know
the inventory was plugged in is like 8
000 or whatever and so they can see that
they only sold 500 of those or whatever
whatever it was and in the first eight
hours you're gonna sell them the
majority yeah right they had hyped it up
and everything
yeah that does seem that that's then the
third option is that they're just going
to steal the money
i mean
which is an interesting option to be
honest
yeah it's but like you know
it's not even that like i mean i'm not
to say that hundred thousand dollars
isn't a lot of money but for them
and it's yeah to do because that's when
you're paying for it without fraud
another option which i think is gonna
happen is that it's gonna be a huge
success it's gonna be massive or it's
gonna at least appear that way without
any explanation as to how they pulled it
off or where the money do you think
they'll pull it off yeah i think so how
the [ __ ] they gonna do with them i mean
the same way
then why'd they stop selling the tickets
that's what i'm saying no one's gonna be
able to explain it but it's gonna be
like the staple setter when they sold
that out like
no but you could see the seats were
there that's what baffles me and i guess
maybe you're right it's just a matter of
that was a few years ago and they've
they've done a lot of scams since then
and they lost the faith of the audience
but i mean this family sold out the
staples but they had chris brown there
mr beast was there they had all these
mega celebrities there paid actors
impersonators
they were impersonators no they were
popping back then that was like when
people trusted them
you think i [ __ ] don't
wash my hands damn
ethan's pretty uh
um
rigorous about watching his hands
actually thank you dan thank you so much
for saying that
appreciate you
no i've noticed
you know i got a newborn son here uh but
why
they've got 2500 attendees
i don't get why they would pop the
pausing doesn't make sense
you cannot put this vessel on for two
hundred thousand dollars you can't do it
yeah no way no way
i mean they could try and it would just
be [ __ ] horrible fire festival status
where like yeah it would be fire
festival yeah
it would be which i mean i'm excited to
see what happens because
you know you know austin and his wife i
forget her name catherine catherine are
like dude we can't do any scams because
people aren't on their [ __ ] this there's
people checking the inventory live
they're like [ __ ]
you know that was very clever the way
that they uh they figured that out by
the way he donated a few minutes ago as
well another a couple bucks and said
thanks for the shout out thank you for
that was very clever how you figured out
how to check their inventory like that
uh carolyn said
just notice the location is palmdale
which is unsafe level of hot in the
summer
high in july like really awesome it's
cheap out there too yeah
yeah so if you're renting a huge ground
for one day in palmdale
that's gonna run probably 20 000 at
least
yeah i mean i could definitely see it
being cheap out there palmdale is um
is
you know it's near la but it's
definitely it's rural it's it's pretty
remote and all right
let's do some rough calculating
20 000 for someone to add these numbers
up okay one sec let me open the
calculator here
all right go ahead 20. so let's just say
20 000 for the grounds yeah
they got a higher staff
yeah um which could i mean it really
depends on the scale of the event but i
mean that can you need security security
alone concessions you need people taking
tickets you need people attending the
rides the games i mean let's see staff
for the one day i don't know
50 grand i mean how many people if you
have it
yeah it could be that it really again
the scale of the event let's say there's
uh
what would you think 50 people 100
people
um well again so they sold enough
tickets for like 2 300. that's not that
many people you know you wouldn't need a
huge amount of staff but you would
think that they're actually shooting to
have like 10 000 people there based off
of the numbers that they put in and if
that's the case i mean yeah as security
alone you're going to want like 50 to 70
security staff
you know people selling concessions
merch i mean we're talking yeah hundreds
of people working there hunter and olive
said they're going to act like the first
round of tickets sold out and they will
re-hype a second release last chance
promotions that's that's a that's
possible but if you believe they sold
out then you're going to like a
dangerously full event that's actually
empty
right okay let's say a hundred employees
you know they get a hundred bucks
because they're paying a minimum wage
so what's that a hundred times a hundred
i guess it's not that much it's like ten
thousand bucks
yeah but if you're talking about for
like security and and like and medics
and stuff like that that's true it
wouldn't be minimum they're gonna need a
permit and all that [ __ ] yeah all right
let's say twenty thousand
yeah i think that's pretty low but let's
just let's just go with it well let's be
let's 25 000. sure
um
they got to bring out rides
food well they're going to generate
money selling food so it's kind of
yeah but people need to operate that
they're they're gonna bring out rides
animals
what if they gotta build a stage and
[ __ ] i mean they're going to an empty
lot
right
yeah i mean i if i was doing something
like this i mean they would probably
partner with with an existing like
carnival
company that you know is kind of turnkey
they show up somewhere
if that's true they're going to be
another lawsuit
maybe
yeah i guess you know if you're planning
on stiffing most of the people that come
work for you
yeah that can affect the money
the money
definitely
i don't see how they could get
all that [ __ ] set up for less than a
hundred thousand i don't see it
bringing up the ride setting it up
breaking it down cleaning the law oh
yeah somebody pointed out and they're
right there didn't the website say the
food was free
oh [ __ ] so they're not even bringing in
money that on food
hell no they didn't say that
did they advertise i don't think it's a
free ride that's for sure i don't
remember no they said free games free
rides free prizes yeah i don't yeah okay
so free food that that would be that
would be
yeah
20 hot dogs folks
yeah i'm having i don't know seeing how
this adds up
there's got to be a hundred thousand to
set that whole thing up
yeah i think there's no way there's no
[ __ ] way
assuming you're doing it safely i mean
we did a pop-up
we spent a hundred thousand dollars on
our pop-up for teddy freddy yeah i mean
yeah i used to before i worked for you i
was in event planning and obviously i
was just like on the broadcast side but
i i saw how a lot of that stuff goes and
it's expensive it's very expensive to do
large events dude
first of all all the people working
there were already teddy fresh employees
right
then like doing the venue and the
decorating and the security we spent a
hundred thousand bucks dude
for a one day event
so like realistically if they're putting
on a whole [ __ ] festival that's gonna
be like three four hundred thousand
dollars yeah
yep that sounds realistic
dude it doesn't make any sense like the
the economics of this it's going to be
awesome man i can't wait to see
well we have tickets we got tickets baby
we got that family pack well i don't
know actually i
don't know if we have tickets we might
we bought we paid we bought tickets we
paid them we don't have tickets
that's true we have a receipt from
shopify as proof that we spent our money
i sent our money to austin right yeah
um
real quick i just know um
hey they have a contact sheet you want
to try to contact them sam
yeah when we try where's my tickets um
it's five o'clock i don't oh i gotta get
out of it you gotta go over don't you
yeah i gotta get out of here and in the
role of a lifetime ila's mom left so
it's like
yeah she was with us for six months a
six months queen yep
soft we love her we miss her
and she left
and
that's going to be a huge blow to me and
eva's productivity i'm playing that
right now sure
which i guess we should say be uh
because we were discussing with ila this
morning but because of that we're going
to
start consistently starting earlier in
the day with the show um so instead of
the we're going to try we're going to
try
well
we're going to see what happens you made
it sound like you're going to need a
bigger ball you got it we'll see what
happens we're going to try our best on
that one okay
before we make any announcements
so when is this happening i i need to i
need i'm very looking forward to july
right
okay that's right around the corner here
folks yeah
i mean
right is summer in palmdale
that does sound miserable 100 degrees i
mean it's rough in the summer
may june they have two months to plan
this thing oh it's in june no it's in
july but i'm saying oh oh how much time
they have to plan yeah they
this this is going to be such a [ __ ]
i don't think it's going to happen i
don't see how it's possible they're
going to cancel it and they're going to
refund people or you know would be cool
because they say yo our partners with
all your money and we have to cancel the
event
reality you guys got scammed the event
of a lifetime of the lifetime of a
lifetime yeah but you make a good point
it's like if they steal two hundred
thousand dollars obviously that's a lot
of money when your rent is fifty
thousand dollars uh that's only floating
you for another couple months right
i don't know what this what let's take a
poll one last poll i'm curious what you
guys think is going to happen
okay what uh
let's see what's going on so
event canceled and refund fast
event cancelled slash refund people are
saying palmdale's california's butthole
i think i didn't want to i didn't want
to go to lancaster
well they're right next to each other
it's the same general area i didn't want
it
yeah oh my god my i still have a family
that lived in lancaster yeah and you
drive out there and you're like where
the [ __ ] am i it is desolate i mean
desolate that's a good word
i believe it's the mojave i mean it's
the mojave desert it's near lancaster i
thought it was like in la area
well that
lancaster is not in la area well then if
you don't lancaster is [ __ ] it's on
the way to vegas it's like oh my god
can you open a map of like
of like
inner la to palmdale
yeah this is so great
cam can't wait to go yeah i can't wait i
hope that there's something for us to go
to
uh palmdale is just south of lancaster
so if you know where lancaster pull up
the map
i'm just making sure there's no like
personal info in here because it is
google maps hold on i think i mean no
offense to
people in lancaster i think you would
agree
uh yeah so i mean here see how there's
nothing there this is los angeles
there's a lancaster here
no way
that gives you an impression you can't
imagine how [ __ ] desolate and
nightmarish this place of this state
yeah this this helps actually i put on
the terrain mode i mean you can see like
can you do a global map
this is google maps
i mean like a street
view let's just drop into a random
street in palmdale california right here
oh
this is a nice suburban area i mean
that's the kind of neighborhood you live
in because it looks nice the
neighborhoods it's just like really
cheap but when you go to the zeta there
you go yeah you can see i mean we're
talking it's like it's the desert it's
the desert it's cool because you can go
there and get a really
a fairly priced nice house
that's why people move out there and
it's awesome you can commute into la and
like actually it's like a two-hour drive
though a lot of people do it but it's
hey if you want to own a house that's
what you do yeah i suppose so
but uh
holy golly gee whiz
that 405 north going out there
unforgiving somebody said it can't be
worse than bakersfield honest similar
vibes similar if you're familiar
bakersfield is more established i feel
like than lancaster maybe
like at least you can buy some meth in
[ __ ]
bakersfield um there's a huge meth
problem in palmdale like
okay so they've caught up
yeah no it's similar vibes for sure to
bakers it is but yeah this place is
dangerous in the summer like you cannot
be out in the open sun for more than
like 15 minutes yeah
dude this is [ __ ] crazy dude there's
many people dying passing out from heat
stroke
there's not enough water just imagine it
it's gonna be like coachella meets
tanacon
tanacon was in l.a temperate beautiful
l.a right yeah people are passing out
there they'll be straight deaths out
there boy
oh my goodness
yeah they said bakersfield is an armpit
but palmdale is a crotch yeah okay
interesting analogy
uh the thing is i've driven through
bakersfield many times sure and there's
like at least like there's like a good
mexican restaurant there you know it was
good mexican anywhere in california not
lancaster
they don't have restaurants there
yeah
um
we never finished this poll you want me
to do okay so what's going on that
happened with afest you said event
cancel slash refund is our first option
cancel it and refund yeah
the second one is
just
cancel and keep money
uh keep the money okay
and then abs uh the the wild card choice
in my opinion is that it happens and
it's all good
baby says without a hitch it says
without a hit
yeah
it's good without explanation it's going
to look good on they're going to make it
look good on camera and video
when realities will be [ __ ] event
canceled with the refund event canceled
but they keep the money goes off without
a hitch
and
uh
is there another option maybe i like the
suggestion that maybe they're actually
going to keep selling tickets and
they're uh
they're just
sold out in order to hype it up kind of
thing but i feel like it still
ultimately fits into one of those three
categories all right well let's just do
the three that works it goes without a
hitch it goes without a hitch
all right i'm asking
now i'm feeling um see what you think
what do you think i genuinely think
because they stopped selling tickets
there's a good chance it's going to be
cancelled refunded i think keeping the
money is even too bold for them like
that's just straight up criminal yeah
wait what about it happens
everyone says it's going to be canceled
keep the money what love i said what if
it happens but it's a disaster i guess
that would have been a good other option
but our fans are are pretty heavily
leaning towards them just straight yeah
they're stealing
there's a good chance it will happen and
it's a disaster love i feel like that's
my guess yeah that's fair
honestly that's the one i'm hoping for
so that we can be there
right i mean that's why we bought that's
why we sent him 500 bucks yeah
i'm looking for a day of family fun
out of this folks
[Laughter]
that's literally austin right now yeah
i am so excited
i can't wait to see what happens yeah
and we'll find out
thank you guys to all the members
there's lots of super troopers
your support means everything i really
appreciate it guys
thank you thank you thank you
appreciate that
oh
well cat cat stir
keep us informed keep an eye on the on
them
we gotta follow caster yep i don't want
to miss any updates on this i love it
i'm not a cat
that guy was a lawyer too
all right i gotta go home and help my
poor wife alrighty
okay thank you guys thank you thank you
thank you
have a great week ahead we'll be back on
wednesday with another banger
banger alert major banger alert hey
[Music]
thank you thank you to our members
thank you to
uh our various guests today
i'm a multitude tree
my parents
mythical chef
matthew what are you shocking us josh
he was so cool
he's the mythical chef i mean if i get
his name wrong you know he's the he's
mythical his name is josh josh
love josh good guy [ __ ] gordon ramsay by
the way he was great jimmy lee we
covered a lot of ground up i know it's
been a it's been a full up roll of a
lifetime
a roll of a lifetime and the roll play
that
gary eldman
and in the role of a lifetime
i'd like to see jamie lee play that
character as well
should we recreate it
i wouldn't think that it might be
appropriate
oh we're supposed to watch tiptoes on
wednesday
oh we heard back from late already
yeah already it's automated uh they said
thank you for your email no tickets will
be emailed due to security reasons you
will need to bring your confirmation
receipt and your id for check-in to
receive your ticket for admission into
the festival so at the door they're
giving you like
tickets at the door security reasons
that's [ __ ] i always get tickets in
the email
that is
that's [ __ ] that's that is the
weirdest answer so they're saying you
got to bring your id
and confirmation
that that auto receipt is what you have
to bring to the door you know what that
means
i think it means that there's literally
no database and they're just letting
anybody in with the receipt because
there's no systems they're just doing it
with shopify there's no services the
shopify system yeah they're not they're
not going to put in any time to verify
my guess is you could show up with a
receipt with random numbers yeah and an
id and they'll let you in
that that's got to be it they're not
investing that's outrageous that it's
outrageous and it was just shopify thing
that doesn't have a ticket thing i've
worked with it before it doesn't have it
built in
that is so [ __ ] outrageous wait so so
sam that was sent automatically
no i just said that as a joke
yo that was super fast
maybe it was people are spamming the red
flag i agree that is a huge
[Music]
all right well that was
that's because there's no barcode or
anything you're just bringing a receipt
like they have no way of verifying you
actually bought that ticket
and then what does your id have to do
with it do they even they don't have so
that you're maybe because you because
they have no other way of verifying so
that your name matches but you bought it
on a company card it doesn't say your
name oh good point
when you bought it okay all right so sam
sounds like you're going sam
golly this is this is really something
i can't wait this is exciting
all right
all right guys thanks for watching we'll
be back on wednesday
with jimmy lee in the role of a lifetime
all right have a good week
[Music]
so
you